But you've got to fake mail now.
You son of a bitch,
it's supposed to be me out me out by the way is welded into the desk of the new
studio desk,
the uh,
the foot of the dead,
the legs of the desk.
I had it made constructive by an artist.
Our friend Eric,
he did a sick job on it and one of the things that he did just on his own is
write the word me out on the side.
Cause this silly bitch says meow at the beginning of every podcast.
You got to appreciate the little things in life studies and John and Brian
brings the bizarre little things.
Just this,
the extra flavor.
It's a salt on the meat.
You know what I'm saying,
son,
we will be in Minneapolis this weekend.
I think there's a couple of tickets left,
but it was,
it was basically almost sold out.
Um,
and that is at the pantageous theater.
It will be Joey motherfucking,
Coco Diaz,
Brian Red band.
And Doug Benson is also going to stop in and do a set.
That shit be crazy.
Yo.
That's an awesome.
So yeah,
we're going to have some fun.
We're going to have some fun and Minneapolis is awesome and it hasn't frozen
over yet,
so we're going to get to him right before shit freezes.
Get in,
get out.
Boom.
We also have a show this Wednesday night at the Ice House,
a 10:00 PM show.
We're going to do these on a regular basis.
I'm not doing it next week because I'm going hunting like a man.
Brian Callen,
Steve Rinella and I are going to go deer hunting.
I'm going to earn my meat bitches or not,
or become a Vegan free counts bitch.
It's very possible psychedelics,
while you're out there
listening,
Jesus son,
Jesus.
But uh,
this Wednesday night it will be a Greg Fitzsimmons,
uh,
Ian Edwards,
I think.
No,
Doug Benson can't do it.
Hans and I saw both of those guys at the La Pod fest.
Greg with hilarious.
Greg is always hilarious.
He's great comic.
Greg and I have been friends for fucking 23 years.
That's when we started doing stand up together.
He's a,
he's old school dude.
Funny as fuck though.
He slayed that audience.
Yeah,
he's a fucking professional.
Um,
uh,
I think,
oh Dunkin Dunkins doing it to too.
Okay.
So,
hey everybody.
So this Wednesday night at the ice house,
it's Ian Dunk,
Ian Edwards.
Fucking hilarious dude.
Duncan Trussell of course.
Hilarious.
Brian Redman,
you know him,
she loves him and uh,
uh,
Greg motherfucking Fitzsimmons so we're going to have a good time.
That's 10 o'clock.
It's 15 bucks and a we do on a regular basis here.
We were asked recently to start doing everyone's day.
So it's as much as a of that as I can.
Sometimes I'm going to be on the road,
but uh,
when I'm,
when I'm in town we're going to try to do it and just a cool place for our
friends to go and do stand up.
And uh,
the guys that you'll see are all going to be really funny guys cause uh,
we don't hang out with my scrubs.
Yo.
You know what I'm saying?
I think my fucking flap talk really quietly.
The Joe Rogan Experience,
oh,
hi primate.
My higher primary t shirts are into,
if you go to higher-primate.com people have been asked.
I finally got all that shit taken care of.
Look,
I'm a fucking terrible businessman,
ladies,
and shut up my only about it,
but I got some dope tee shirts.
I supposed to do my taxes today.
Whoops.
Whoops,
though you're a terrible business person too.
I'm horrible.
I was like,
Hey,
I'll just take the whatever the,
the,
you get fined or something like money.
Right.
It's not like you go to prison immediately,
right?
No.
I think you get to pay it,
but you get fine.
Yeah.
Just do that.
The
type of brain that you know is like really organized.
That's not the type of person that does a silly podcast.
It's a totally different type of brain.
I'm convinced of that.
You know,
I fight with my,
uh,
illogical tendencies and my procrastination in,
in,
in pulse liveness and craziness.
But I think that's the only way comedians,
brains work,
I don't think.
Yeah.
I think it's just a constant struggle to try to mend it.
The society with that fucking whacked down noodle on your head,
Bryan red band.
Anyway,
higher-primary.com.
That's the tee shirt company.
It's all like monkeys and mushrooms and shit and,
and there's a really cool Joey d shirt and they're very soft shirts.
High Quality.
Sure.
Regular like fucking normal shirts.
It's like the highest quality we can get.
We got really high quality soft tee shirts,
so it's like a fashion tee shirt,
you know,
that was the options.
The options were spent a lot of money on really expensive tee shirts or sell
cheap ones.
But I think they'd come out cool this way.
It's,
they're expensive,
they're not cheap,
but they're really well made.
So that's what it is on [inaudible] dot coms or other sponsor.
Uh,
if you go to o n n it and use a code name,
Rogan,
you will save 10% off any of the supplements.
The explanations for all these supplements are all also at on it.
I do a terrible job explaining these things.
Perhaps Dave Asprey could help us because he's far smarter than I and these
things.
Um,
but I don't really know what's going on.
I just don't want to use it.
It's awesome.
And there's a bunch of studies that say the stuff inside of it is awesome.
A Alpha brain is my favorite supplement period I had.
So one thing that I make sure I don't go anywhere without,
if I'm doing a podcast to bring it with me,
I'm doing a comedy show,
I bring it with me.
I take it before every UFC.
Uh,
it's not going to turn a genius or a moron into a genius,
but I really definitely feel like it gives me a mental boost,
if that makes any sense.
And there's been shut studies have shown that the ingredients in the doses that
we use it have had positive effects and studies.
So we're,
we're doing our own studies right now.
It takes 10 to 12 months for a double blind placebo study,
uh,
from this university in Boston.
And when they're done,
they take it and the,
you know,
process all the information and figuring out whether or not it's legit.
So we'll,
we'll have actual studies,
but the ingredients that are in the study or the ingredients,
whether they're in Alpha brain,
in the doses that we use,
have shown positive results.
It just,
no one's ever proven that there's a synergistic effect of all the ingredients
together.
That's the controversial aspect of it.
Here's the deal though,
the way we have it set up at on it,
you get 100% money back from the first 30 pills.
If you don't think it works,
if it's not your thing,
everybody's body's different.
I don't know what you feel,
and I know some people can't drink.
I know some people can't smoke pot.
Some people can't eat.
The bodies are different.
If it's not,
if you don't feel it,
I'm going to what your sensitivity is.
If you don't think it's worth it,
you get a hundred percent money back.
You don't have to return the product.
Nobody's trying to rip you off.
We're trying to sell you shit that I use everything.
We sell it on it,
whether it's vitamins or the BLENDTEC blenders that are coming in tomorrow.
We start selling house because Kale shakes pitches.
You got to get your morning started off correct.
I'm telling you the way to live life,
it's,
it's a healthier way to get out of bed.
That's my newest phrase,
by the way.
I say that all to Kale,
shake pitches.
Kale shakes his fucking guy in the underground side.
I went to the supermarket and there was no Kale.
Damn you,
Joe Rogan.
I noticed like restaurants.
I'll have like Kale,
everything like Kale,
Caesar Salads now Kale.
Yeah.
When we were in Phoenix,
I had a Kale Caesar Salad.
Yeah.
I think Kale is becoming more popular now.
It's just one of the people.
It's a super food.
I mean people are realizing how it's,
it's really,
it's got a lot of protein in [inaudible].
Crazy.
Good for you.
It's really fucking good for you and when you have it in this massive dose.
The way I do it,
I take the,
the,
the recipes available at [inaudible] Dot com my recipe,
my recipe is pretty extreme.
It's got a lot of garlic in it.
It's got a lot of ginger in it,
and it's got a fucking wall up plug.
It hits you.
It's,
it's intense,
but Ooh,
you feel good afterwards.
God Damn,
everything just feels
it's alive.
Um,
anyway,
we also sell kettle bells,
battle ropes.
Like I said,
we have the BLENDTEC blenders coming in and the supplements,
there's new mood,
which is a great five HTP and l tryptofan supplement that it enhances your,
your brain's production of Serotonin and l Tryptofan converts into five HTP and
five HTP converts into Serotonin,
right?
So I correct.
Yep.
Yeah.
And this is all done.
Here's all the scientific studies behind all this stuff.
And all the information available is not just an audit.com,
but at Google,
if you Google nootropics,
you'll get a better idea of whether or not you're interested in anything.
Um,
the most important thing to worry to,
to,
uh,
to have on mine.
Those,
you don't have to worry about it.
So they're just new trans,
it's not drugs.
You're not going to test positive for anything at work,
including the hemp force protein.
That's a big question that comes up all the time.
If you have the hemp force protein,
no you will.
There's no way you can taste positive or rather test positive for marijuana.
Hemp is completely non psychoactive.
It's just a protein.
It's just plants.
It's just,
it's not.
It's like a cousin to pot and it's illegal.
Unfortunately.
You can grow it,
you can buy it and you can sell it,
but you can't grow it,
which is a fucking crazy.
It just shows you what a silly,
silly,
silly government we have cause it's an awesome plan.
It's got all the amino acids in it you can make fuel out of.
At Henry Ford made one of his first cars out of it and the,
the fiber of the hemp plant is so durable.
It's really like an alien planet.
The fact that we don't use it,
just the hemp part,
forget about the pot smoking pot.
Forget about all that.
Completely pretend that pot didn't exist.
It was never invented.
No one ever had it.
The hemp itself,
making something like hemp illegal is one of the dumbest things a human being
can do.
It's almost like making apples illegal.
It's worse than making apples illegal because you can't make a house out of
apples.
They make a fucking house at a hemp.
You can construct cars out of it that are stronger than steel.
It's insane how strong the fibers of this shit is.
It makes a far superior paper.
It makes far superior clothing.
Things that don't rip,
but the reason why it's illegal is because way back in the 1930s they invented a
machine called the decorticator and that decorticator takes hemp fiber and it
breaks it down and it turns it into something that's useful.
It's a long and lengthy process that they used to use slaves for though in
slavery became illegal.
It's much easier to get cotton and use cotton than it is to use hemp,
so that's why it's illegal.
They all conspired,
all these people that didn't want to lose out to the hemp industry in the cotton
industry,
in the paper industry,
especially William Randolph Hearst,
he ran newspapers and he printed stories about Mexican smoking marijuana and
raping white women.
It was all like just craziness to get this one plant illegal and it was actually
for its use as a commodity.
That's what they were trying to squash had nothing to do with it being
psychoactive.
It's amazing that that it,
that hustle has lasted so long.
Anyway,
we have hemp protein that we buy from Canada and it's the shit it's called hemp
force.
What are you doing?
You're doing like,
exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't handle the truth either.
I can't heal the truth cause even when I say it when I say that,
like that store that I just told,
I know that to be a fact of reddit everywhere.
It sounds so dumb.
It sounds so ridiculous.
It makes me angry.
It's like people are,
people are just beyond stupid.
Brian.
Yes.
Anyway,
enough of me.
Go to ana.com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
Oh,
I almost forgot the tangle that got a lot of fucking commercials,
man.
If I was on an internet,
I would be complaining about me right now.
A lot of commercials.
You just always go really long on the Onnit one.
Well,
you know,
here's the thing.
I go along on anything that I absolutely believe in it because you're on it.
I am on it and it also is because I would,
I do in the middle.
I don't know how everybody else is doing them,
but I think a lot of people are sticking them in the conversations now.
I know that that's what Adam Carolla does.
He does like podcasts and then he does commercial is like a radio show that I
think that fucks with me.
Maybe that's why the flashlight was pretty fun because I can always bring the
flat side.
It's like the olive garden.
Yes.
You always could.
I don't think we should keep it as a sponsor just for that reason.
Ting is an excellent product though and everything we sell on his podcast,
I guess we're selling things.
Everything we promote,
there we go.
Everything we're paid to promote is,
is things that we believe in 100%.
Um,
you don't ever have to worry about us trying to rip you off.
If there's anything that's being talked about on this podcast,
it's always going to be 100% to the best of my knowledge.
And if I'm ever incorrect,
I will definitely know that I fucked up and everything that we're selling,
whether it's through on it or through audible.com or even ting is,
what are you doing with the team that's not the same pin pong?
What is Ting?
Ting is a cell phone service that you,
you sign up for and they use sprints,
backbone and they sell cool phones.
Like android phones.
Like the galaxy s three is big fucking cool.
Last one that you see in the commercials every day lately.
And um,
they have it set up so that you can quit it anytime you,
you don't have to have contracts.
Your minutes can pile on to like more than one phone.
Like you can share minutes with like,
you know,
your wife.
Um,
and you also,
if you don't use a certain amount of minutes every month,
if you're allotted a certain amount of minutes and you don't use them,
you're dropped dropdown and credited to the lower level of a payment plan.
So they actually give you money back.
I mean it's a really,
it's a really,
it's like,
it's a really fair company.
It's like I love the,
the,
the ethical way in which they're choosing to do business there.
They're saying,
we make plenty of money.
Let's just do this really fair.
Let's sell people a quality product.
Like all these killer,
uh,
android phones,
they have regular phones too.
If you're into flip phones.
But what they decided to do is use this big company's network,
use sprints,
backbone,
which is a huge,
then we can't come up with your own,
but then,
you know,
use it in a way that they feel is fair.
And so they provide an excellent service and they give you cool phones and you
can quit at any time.
I mean,
there's no contracts.
It's,
it's a really,
it's a beautiful situation and that's really what I think it should be with
every cell phone company.
It's crazy that you get locked into these contracts and they rope you in by
giving you some crazy discount on his phone and it suits all bananas.
But the bottom line is if you want to leave cause your service,
your service sucks.
It costs a lot of money.
Well,
not with Tang Tang,
you just,
you just bail.
That's it.
Go to rogan.ting.com and you'll save 50 bucks off your first digital cellular
device for talking to people through the air and you took it beyond Ting.
All right pitches,
Dave Asprey's here.
We're going to get to the bottom of things.
We're going to get an educated,
we're going to get experienced who?
That's my new,
that's my new tagline of being in a very show.
It's just cheesy as it gets.
We're going to get some experience trying by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Dude,
we're getting experienced.
We just got out of it from being on it and now we're getting it back in it.
We're experienced.
Dude.
That's how I'm feeling that right now.
Dave,
thanks for coming man.
Really appreciate it.
Tait Fletcher is your number one
fan.
Boy.
So please give a big shout out at the beginning of this podcast.
Tate,
you rock man.
Date as bulletproof,
everything.
Every fucking tweety sends stay bulletproof.
My friends,
it's like he's like the most interesting man in the world,
but it's about bulletproof.
You know,
instead of stay thirsty,
he totally rocks.
He loves you man.
He's got a fucking serious man crush on your ideas.
Homeboy came in with a jug.
I love pate.
Me and Tate both have the coffee addiction.
I love him for a bunch of reasons,
but that's one of them.
We both have the coffee addiction and take comes in with this fucking ridiculous
like camping for a month mug filled with bulletproof coffee and he poured bees
up.
It was pretty bad ass man.
That was the first,
uh,
my first experience with bulletproof coffee.
And this is your creation.
Yup.
And for folks who don't understand what bulletproof coffee is,
what it consists of,
what's a,
what's in exactly.
It's low toxin coffee,
which has a different mental effect to than the normal stuff.
This will,
you can just buy on any street corner.
You blend it with grass fed butter that has certain fatty acids,
short chain fatty acids.
Your brain needs for anti-inflammatory purposes and you blend it with either
coconut oil or MCT oil,
which is an extract of coconut oil that six times stronger and you blend it.
It gets foamy and froth.
He just liked the best latte you ever had.
It doesn't taste gross.
It doesn't taste buttery,
oily,
and when you drink it you are full for eight hours and you have this incredible
focus.
This mental focus,
it's,
it's just insane.
Whoa.
How's that possible?
What is it doing?
It's just,
it's,
it's causing,
it's like a synergistic effect with the butter and the oil and the coffee.
It makes the stimulant last longer.
Is that what it is?
Well,
the hunger part happens because your body is getting the short and medium chain
fatty acids that are really hard to get in your diet,
so because you're doing that,
you're already getting a big boost there and then we believe that it probably
helps to escort the terpenes that are inside coffee,
like caffeine,
strong cow hall,
that the psychoactive compounds that are not caffeine.
We think it helps those go into the brain.
And the other reason that I'm theorizing that it gives you this kind of boost is
because of the small drops of fat that are formed when you blend it or called
Micelles and they absorbed better into the body and your body can burn MCT for
energy without any digestive process required at all.
This is the thing that like bodybuilders used to get lean and ripped when
they're in the shedding phase.
It also happens to cure Alzheimer's disease and it makes you feel really good.
I put it in my Kale shakes.
I put four big teaspoons tablespoons of coconut oil and it tastes good.
Yeah,
so we've got a good taste to it.
Everyone should be eating coconut oil unless they're allergic to coconut.
It's that straight forward.
Do you remember when they were saying the coconut oil is bad for you?
When we were kids,
just like the American soil association got one in there.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
they did a like a six week study of hydrogenated coconut oil versus their crappy
oil and then what do you know?
It raise cholesterol and til this day you ask the average like 40 50 year old
American.
You say coconut oil,
they say cholesterol and you're like,
there's not in there.
I'm like,
it's cholesterol free.
Not that it's a problem.
It has cholesterol but salt.
That's another one.
People are so silly.
Salt.
Salt gives you a high blood pressure.
No.
Salt is a fucking mineral.
You dummies.
It's as an essential mineral and you can have too little of it.
Saul is not making you fat.
That is so crazy that that thought that salt is making you fat has always driven
me fucking bananas.
It's going to give you high blood pressure with all that salt.
Do you know that?
That that it raises your blood pressure within the error margin of a blood
pressure cuff.
That's it.
But it's meaningless.
And why does everybody connect salt,
the high blood pressure it has to do with the marketing of an anti uh,
blood pressure drugs.
So they found out back in about 1960 that that was how,
uh,
that,
that was a way to lower blood pressure.
Well,
if you get people to basically pay more water out,
their blood gets thicker so then their blood pressure goes down.
So they started looking at salts effect on that and they went down this path and
get this in 1997,
the Lancet medical journal,
which is kind of a bad ass one,
they published a whole thing about how the salt myth didn't work,
how there was scientific fraud,
how people probably should have gone to jail for spending taxpayer money and
making up data.
And yet to this day,
you still hear government campaigns to lower salt consumption,
knowing full well that it makes your adrenals break when you don't get enough
salt.
I do 10 grams a day.
I have for 10 years.
I carry a vial of it around with me.
I wouldn't think of starting in the morning without a teaspoon of salt.
Whoa.
Every morning in your shakes.
Yeah,
there's a reason for it.
Okay.
What kind of salt?
What's the best?
I like the Himalayan crystal salt.
It's still just cause it comes from the Himalayas
as his dope,
bringing back some fucking Himalayan salt son,
you know,
and there's other kinds of,
any kind of sea salt is going to do it,
but there's less pollution in the Himalayan stuff.
And I like the idea that it's aren't that it's mind to buy one arm to monks.
It's just,
is it really,
you know,
grass fed.
So imagine the only way to get a job,
there's,
you know,
chop off one of your arms dues would do it.
There's enough people out there that would do it.
Probably were fucking crazy,
man.
I guarantee you they would do it.
So what is the benefit of putting the salt in your body every morning?
Here's what happens when you wake up in the morning,
when you first wake up,
your body says,
and this is like your reptilian brain,
the low level parts of your operating system,
you don't pay any attention to,
oh,
I mean the whole thing.
Exactly.
So you wake up and it says,
hmm,
this,
this body is going to stand up in a minute.
And when it stands up,
I've got to have enough blood pressure in the brain if I don't have enough blood
pressure in the brain and he's going to pass out in a tiger going to eat him.
So this is like a survival level imperative inside your body.
So what does it do?
It goes to your adrenal glands and says,
hey buddy,
could you crank up some cortisol and could you change the sodium to potassium
ratio?
I need you to find sodium,
which is hard for people to do.
That's why we used to pay our soldiers in salt instead of in gold.
And then it says crank down and potassium crank up on sodium.
If in the morning you take your sodium and you drink it,
soon after you wake up,
your adrenal glands don't have to do all that work.
So then you have that adrenal function for the rest of the day to feel good.
All
right,
I'll do it.
Or you pulled it out.
Yeah.
Can you put it back up
Tony?
How,
what,
what's happening here folks,
your uh,
your adrenal glands are more relaxed.
I actually recommend this,
especially for women when they're pregnant because they have enough stress
already.
I have a book coming out in January about like how to have better genes and
bigger brains in your kid's starting even before you get pregnant.
The knowingness,
having this knowledge in your head,
does it infuriate you when you see these lower salt,
you know,
campaigns and you hear people talking about it,
like,
you know,
lower a low salt foods.
Like what?
What is that?
It used to infuriate me,
but to be honest,
I've done enough of the meditation and the brain hacking.
Like I don't get mad at stuff like that cause it,
it's not worth the cost of getting mad.
But what I do is I do something about it.
Like that's why I started the bulletproof exact blog.
It's that there's a lot of this knowledge.
I used to weigh 300 pounds.
I was profoundly unhealthy for the first half of my life and no one taught me
any of the things that my body can do.
It's just the knowledge wasn't out there and now it is,
but there's a credibility problems and I'm like,
look,
I'm a pretty successful guy and I wouldn't have been this successful if I hadn't
learned all this stuff.
So here it is and it's free.
I just give it to people.
I've got seven people working for me now doing this.
Wow.
So you were 300 pounds and how old were you when this was going on?
See,
I hit a 23 years old.
I hit 300 pounds to 97 hours.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's big.
What was that like?
I mean,
it sucked.
I was fat as a teenager to horrible diet.
Well,
I thought I was eating the right stuff.
You know,
I,
in fact during that time I worked out six days a week for an hour and a half a
day and I ate 1800 calories.
You know what?
If your hormones are Jack,
you're not going to lose weight.
I did eat less than my thin friends.
I just couldn't lose the weight.
I was tired all the time too.
And you have thyroid,
anything with your thought?
I did have some thyroid issues,
but it wasn't just thyroid.
Like there's all kinds of toxin and even like swelling that happens in the body.
If you have chronic inflammation turned on,
you're going to be storing a third of your fat.
Maybe it's not even fat,
it's just like tissue inflammation.
So for me,
I had to figure out what was causing my inflammation and what's your cortisol
level?
So there's all these delicate hormones that you manipulate through your food and
through your environment and the idea that calories in,
calories out matters.
I tell you,
I ran this experiment.
It was a little crazy.
I know that the calorie thing is completely broken because we're not robots.
You know,
we're not like a car.
You put gas in and you get so many miles.
As long as the wind resistance is the same.
So I thought I would eat 4,000 calories a day.
I'd sleep five hours a night or less and I'd stop exercising and I thought maybe
I'll gain,
you know,
a couple pounds in a month or two and I'll say,
look,
I should have gained 10 pounds.
I gained two pounds.
I went for two years.
I posted a picture of a six pack that grew during that time.
I should have weighed 616 pounds after two years of this program.
I'm not counting the sleep deficit and I weighed two 10 at the end of it.
And actually it was more muscular than I was before.
Of course,
I was drinking bulletproof coffee,
I was doing bulletproof intermittent fasting,
which I developed during that time,
which is intermittent fasting.
But you have only fat in the morning,
which gives you this huge boost,
the one that Tate was talking about when he was here with you.
So can do all these crazy things with the body.
But I'll,
I'll tell you a fight out like fat doesn't make you fat and calories don't make
your fat calories fuel your brain though they're useful,
but they're not a very good way of measuring your intake of food.
So what is it?
What?
How does someone get fat?
Then it turns out things like Leptin resistance,
things like inflammation in the gut and things like insulin all play a role
there.
What happens is your mitochondria and your cells also can get weak.
You actually get used to having eat every two hours is this idea of frequent
snacking to keep your energy up.
What you're doing is you're teaching the body to actually like need to not be
able to store,
to not be resilient.
It's not be able to store any kind of calories at all.
What I do is I teach my body to burn fat and I keep my calories at at least 50%
of my calories are coming from fat.
And most of that is saturated fat with some Omega threes mixed in.
And what happens there is I can eat pretty much as much as I can stand and I
won't gain any weight that way.
So it's,
it's simply what causes obesity isn't one single thing.
But I will tell you one of the unknown things that is a major contributor is
synthetic estrogen in the environment.
A lot of that comes from mold in our food supply.
It's called Zarrella known.
We actually purify it and feed it to industrial beef.
We put it in a little waxy pellet in the cow's ear.
And here's an example of how much this stuff works you use around unknown.
It can increase what they call feed efficiency for livestock by 30% feed
efficiency means if I don't give them this drug and I give him a pound of food,
they gain,
you know,
however many ounces of fat or or meat that the cow is going to gain.
You put this pellet in their area changed or hormonal function,
they gain 30% more weight on the same amount of food.
That stuff is fat soluble and it bioaccumulates.
You do not want to be eating hormone treated beef that was treated to get fat
really,
really quickly.
So we know flat out just because in animal husbandry,
if we can change the calories in,
calories out equation by 30% why couldn't we do in humans and the answer as we
can and that's why every time someone tells me,
measure how much you eat and measure how much you exercise and you'll lose
weight.
It's the biggest myth.
I have the whole a whole big like research,
like 30 references,
a blog post about that.
It's just not true.
It never was.
So when someone drops their calories down and exercises and starts losing fat,
what,
what are they doing?
You can do it for a little while but here's what happens and I can tell you this
cause I did that lots of times you lose 25 pounds again,
25 pounds to lose 25 pounds.
So it's a slingshot sort of a thing and there's something called epigenetics and
epigenetics is like one of the main subject of this book that I wrote and it's,
it's awesome because epigenetic shows how the environment changes the expression
of your genes and you get signals from the environment all the time and two of
the biggest signals that you can ever send your body that changed the way you
actually methalate your DNA are,
there's a threat,
there's something chasing me and it won't stop.
And you do this by going for a run every single day without rest instead of
practicing high intensity interval training or instead of giving yourself some
recovery time.
There's a lot of athletes and even non athletes who are just playing overtrained
they don't get enough recovery time to actually build the muscle up that they
should build cause they had to go rip it down again by lifting the next day.
Right.
So that's one signal,
which is that like there's a threat to my species because I keep getting injured
on a daily basis.
I keep having to run.
The other signal you can send is there's a famine and you tell your body there's
a famine by eating low calories or low fat diets.
When you do that,
it changes your gene expression.
And we know that people who went through a famine that their grandkids have a
two to three times higher chance of getting type two diabetes.
This stuff passes down through the generations.
So I'll tell you flat out,
like if you're going on,
especially a low fat Vegan Diet and you're planning to reproduce,
your kids are going to be weaker than they would have been before.
And the evidence there is pretty darn strong.
It's a multiple generation of fact.
Wow.
So a Vegan diet is lacking.
And what it's lacking in saturated fat.
For one thing,
a way to make up for it in with a Vegan Diet,
if you're conscious about it,
you can get some in coconut oil,
but coconut oil does not have conjugated linoleic acid.
It doesn't have a lot of the micronutrients that are present in animal products.
You can probably get by on a vegetarian,
a very careful vegetarian by it,
but diet,
but in terms of being like fully optimal as in kicking ass at the maximum level
of what the human body can do,
it's going to take more than just egg yolks.
It's going to take some steak and it's going to take some lamb and it's going to
take some cod liver oil and things like that.
If you're going to be 100% Vegan.
I honestly,
I know enough people now who've posted on my blogs,
even some close personal friends.
Uh,
one of them was a black belt in Aikido.
He went vegan and 18 months later he's allergic to everything.
Like you had to go back.
But it,
it seriously just decimated as health.
So it's,
it's a careful thing to do,
but I know people who do and they're very healthy guys like Mack Dansik,
he's very healthy and he's uh,
he's been a Vegan for years.
There definitely are some very healthy vegans.
I'm friends with some Erin Simpson,
one of the guys are fights in the UFC.
Very healthy guy.
He's a Vegan.
Um,
how old are these guys?
Aaron I think is 36.
37 so I'm really curious when I was younger,
what their blood work looks like,
I'd love to see like an antiaging panel from one of those guys.
I don't know if any of them has ever posted it,
but I'd love to just go through it and look at their triglycerides from all the
fructose they eat.
I mean,
that's one serious thing.
There's c reactive protein.
Every antiaging physician I've worked with,
and when I say that,
I run an antiaging nonprofit group called Silicon Valley Health Institute,
SUV ahi.com or.org.
We've been around for 19 years,
bringing guys in like Aubrey de grey,
other like big time antiaging people to give lectures and to a tee,
every single one of them except one has said flat out,
I won't take a Vegan patient because I cannot make them age less quickly.
Like it just doesn't work.
And these are the guys who like see 10 patients a day with carefully
demonstrated panels.
It,
the bottom line is it's,
I would love it if the Vegan diet was,
was safe and effective.
I was a raw vegan for about four months and after that I became a Ra,
omnivore for another six or seven months before I went off to Tibet and China.
I'm not eating raw yak and into bed.
No,
no.
I,
yeah,
it was kind of hanging out from the mud wall.
I'm like,
you better cook that
Yak.
Huh?
Was He actually sorry.
It's actually awesome.
Some of the best meat I've ever had.
It's really,
it's better than grass fed beef.
Even like the best Primo grassfed.
Really?
Yeah.
Huh?
What do you think people would know about that?
Well,
the problem is it only eats some kind of weird moss that grows at high altitude
and it dies when you bring it to low altitude.
So it's kind of a constrained supply.
Oh Wow.
That's fascinating to seriously tough animal though.
Jakks yeah,
I mean they're,
they're ginormous.
Like most of the things you see are only half.
Yeah,
calf cow.
But the real ones are bigger than a camp.
Tangy.
Tastes good.
I would think they'd be like real gamey.
Yeah.
Funky.
Pizza Yag Layman,
you know.
Oh yeah,
it was awesome.
So this is an incredibly fascinating subject to me because I've always wondered
like what it is about certain people,
they store so much fat and certain people just stay lean no matter what.
Some of that,
obviously it's genetics,
but what is wrong with their diet that takes a person and just,
it blows them up to three 5,400 pounds.
I mean,
it's,
there's gotta be a,
this is a critical issue,
right?
Is it sugar?
Is it a,
what is it as imposters and carbs that turn to sugar?
It's actually sugar plus inflammation.
So it's that combination of Omega six,
like excess Omega six oils plus sugar and corn syrup and things like that.
What you're doing is you're basically just just completely wrecking the
metabolism when you do that.
A mega six oils have lots of polyunsaturated bonds.
I'm talking corn oil,
canola oil,
stuff like that,
and vegetable oil,
what happens,
their soils and other one,
every unsaturated bond in that oil can oxidize and what oxidizes it is oxygen,
heat and light.
So most of these roles get oxidized before you even eat them.
But in the body you try and make cell walls out of them and when that happens
you end up with less flexible cell walls that aren't able to express the insulin
receptors very well.
Right.
So we ended up with lots of problems like that because we ended up getting these
oils that oxidize easily when they're oxidized inside the body,
they make free radicals.
So you get general systemic inflammation and you can measure these levels.
Like if you take a Vegan and you look at their Omega six to Omega three ratio,
it can be 30 40 to one the average American on a crap industrial meat diet is at
40 to one right now.
My blood levels are 1.28 to one of my Omega six to Omega three ratios and that
helps me to crank my inflammation way down and it helps me to express healthy
insulin receptors so I don't get insulin resistance.
I don't get Leptin resistance and that lets me,
even now I could go out,
I can eat a relatively heavy sugar meal.
I don't get a coma from it even though I used to get a coma from it when I
weighed 280 pounds or 300 pounds.
I can also go 18 hours without eating and it doesn't bother me in the slightest
and that's a pretty big difference from,
I used to be the guy,
I'm like,
it's 1145 I got to,
I got,
we got to end this meeting right now because I have to eat because if I need it
I'm going to kill someone.
You can go 18 hours.
Yeah.
In fact I did it yesterday.
I had my last meal at 4:00 PM last night and then again at two today.
I guess that was a little more than 22 hours.
No.
What do you say about people that say that you should have like some sort of a
post workout?
Um,
sugary meal,
some like a lot of glucose,
high glucose,
a little bit of protein.
What do you think about that?
I looked at that and what you're trying to do there is you're trying to spike
your insulin afterwards because the insulin,
we have insulin like growth factor IGF one which has caused you to build
muscles.
It's insulin light cause it has the same effects as insulin.
So you had a lot of sugar spike your insulin allegedly lay down more muscle.
There's a couple of studies I've seen and I can't cite sources from memory right
now,
but what I,
what I recall from seeing them is that it looks like the effect and Igf one
probably isn't as good as you'd like it to be.
What I do after I work out is I typically have a good amount of protein,
a good amount of fat and some starch,
not a lot,
and I choose low toxin starches,
which is kind of hard to do.
I've got the bulletproof diet up on the site where it's a free,
but it's an infographic that basically ranks foods based on three criteria and
if you get a bulletproof starch,
like a white rice that's properly rents in cooked or a sweet potatoes,
butternut squash,
things like that,
what you're doing is you're getting your carbs up enough that you can still even
stay in a state of ketosis.
Maybe,
maybe not.
But what you can do there is you can reduce your stress hormone levels and that
eating right after you work out drops cortisol.
If your cortisol doesn't get dropped in that postworkout window,
you get a cortisol spike that lasts for 48 hours,
so you're not going to get as much muscle.
It's absolutely critical to eat.
But do you need sugar or do you need protein and fat?
I would tend towards protein and fat with a small amount of starch.
So how did it get started that people learned how to drink chocolate milk?
That was like the big thing for awhile it was like chocolate milk is the best
post workout drink.
You know there's effects from milk on IGF one as well.
Like milk will cause you to put on weight because you to put on fat to build.
If you want to look up,
you know milk works for bulking up.
Why chocolate milk?
Because someone said,
oh it's raising the insulin some more,
but kind of look at what's in chocolate milk.
At least make your own with real chocolate.
What is in chocolate?
It's usually high fructose corn syrup.
Like terrible for you.
Yeah.
And plus you've got problems with when you homogenized milk,
you take those fat droplets that your body really needs and you put them through
a super fine screen under pressure,
which makes these extremely fine fat droplets that your body doesn't know how to
handle.
They can actually enter cells.
So imaginization can increase inflammation and it causes weird fat reactions
that that your body's not ready for.
And also when they pasteurize the milk,
you get a case in and case is an inflammatory compounds depending on how it's
processed.
But it's a very careful protein.
I don't need any case and I know lots of people who are just playing allergic to
it and I mean you've probably had people in here talking about the China study.
That was an incredibly misrepresentative book,
but one of the key points at the very beginning was that case and can increase
inflammation and be linked to liver cancer.
And that's actually true.
So man,
in order to get some protein,
you're getting case which has been pasteurized.
You're getting fat and the wrong form,
you're getting high fructose corn syrup.
I could probably formulate a better post workout drink using MCT oil,
like bulletproof flow talks and chocolate.
Maybe you could use honey.
Even like raw honey has a different effect than say normal sugar does and normal
sugar has a different effect on high fructose corn syrup.
What is the deal was corn?
Why?
Why do we use so much corn?
It's high fructose corn syrup and corn is in so many different to everywhere.
Is that a lobby thing?
Is that,
yup.
Corn and soy are lobby things and also farm subsidies,
right?
You know,
you grow corn and soy,
you get extra money from the government for growing this stuff.
We've got the whole Monsanto connection there,
which is just beyond evil.
From my perspective,
it's confusing,
very confusing that it's real.
It's very confusing.
If there's a company out there that's trying to make these genetically modified
food and then force farmers to grow them.
And when you see the suicide rates in India,
they're,
they're absolutely stunning.
I mean it's like they're having suicides there every day.
All Day long.
People are killing themselves because of Monsanto.
There's been hundreds of thousands of suicides in India link to Monsanto.
It's,
it's really crazy.
These poor farmers,
there's even more profound evil going on.
And one of my pet peeves,
things I talk about and I've studied extensively is called mycotoxins.
And these are toxins that form from fungus in the environment.
And the combination of dupont plus Monsanto is a shocking story.
Like 30 years ago,
dupont made this pesticide called Benno mill.
And what been a mill did is it killed all fungus,
like 98% of fungus it touched,
which is die.
Unfortunately the other 2% would get like x man mutation turned on.
So whole plasmid level mutation it's called.
What this means is that instead of one gene mutating like nature does,
whole groups or deans would mutate and get this.
A fungus can change plasmids,
plasmids like baseball cards with other fungus.
So what's going on here is we create an x men fungus that reproduce every 20
minutes 30 years ago,
and some of these new toxic molds that are like Uber vicious,
you know that,
that poisoned people in their houses and all I've had that happen to me,
you know,
Stacie buttress and Aspergillus in your kitchen will mess your head up sometimes
permanently.
And what's going on is Ben a made these toxic,
but then you spray roundup on soil.
Roundup completely disrupts the soil microbes.
These are like the probiotics of the planet.
Like our soil health is really important.
So now you get mutated x men stuff growing in the soil and then you piss it off
with roundup.
You get 500 times more toxins and then that mold that's left fusarium grows in
the corn.
In fact,
it's a major pests.
It's a major pest for corn in the u s you get dried corn with toxic mold forming
fusarium in it.
It a majorly large percentage.
I don't know for this year,
some years it's up to 98% of corn has this toxic mold growing in it.
What?
It's crazy stuff.
And this is not like any kind of weird,
you know,
conspiracy theory thing.
This is documented in agricultural science,
just known in biochemistry that I know of,
tends to read the studies on mycotoxins cause they're all like often
agricultural land instead of unhealth land.
So you're saying that 98% of corn has this microtoxin in it and it's not killed
by any production process turning into bread or turning it into corn bread or
tortillas or anything like that?
It's a micro,
not micro.
I'm Yco like as in Miko,
like mushroom derived.
Yeah,
like my sales.
Right.
And some of it is killed.
We've heard of these mycotoxins before.
Aflatoxin.
Everyone knows that's a bad one in peanuts or penicillin,
like a tiny little little capsule.
Penicillin,
which has just mold extract has this profound effect on your body,
right?
Well,
there's other stuff out there that has a profound effect on your body at a parts
per million level.
And I don't know if this year 98% of corn is,
that's the maximum I found in my data,
but at least a third almost every year in the u s of corn of dried corn product
that's out there like animal feed,
like Masa,
like corn tortillas has stuff in it.
And for,
sorry,
I missed three classes of toxins that mess with your brain and with your
hormones and with your protein formation.
And that's why on the bulletproof diet,
I look first at macronutrients and then I look at anti nutrients like mycotoxins
and hitch heterocyclic amines and all the others.
And you gotta be a little careful in your food if you want to like really kick
ass and be mentally focused all the time.
These are the things that get in there and muck with your head.
Some people are more sensitive than others,
but if you reduce the level of these things in your diet,
you think better and that's one reason you do the bulletproof diet in the
morning.
All you're drinking with bulletproof intermittent fasting is low toxin coffee,
low talks and butter and toxin free MCT oil.
You do that.
You've had nothing messing with your head.
Only good stuff,
no bad stuff.
Dad is absolutely fascinating so everyone's being poisoned.
Essentially.
Everyone who's eating all these corn products is being poisoned.
Yup.
At low levels they are and the links between heart disease and cancer and
mycotoxins are very well established.
In fact,
the WHO researcher who's written the most research of anyone on Mycotoxins as a
whole book,
this thick,
uh,
called Fungal bionics where he cites 900 different studies about the links
between atherosclerosis and cancer.
That's heart disease.
Direct quote from this author.
He says there was a known cause of atherosclerosis and it is mycotoxins.
Pig farmers know this.
They know that if they get great these grains that have mold growing in them,
they have test kits they can buy where they test the grain because they know
they feed too much grain to the key to the pigs.
The pigs will get lesions in their arteries or the pigs will lose their litter
before they can deliver it.
But what they do is they wait until the pigs are far enough along.
Then they feed the cheaper toxic grain to the pigs or the cows and that fattens
them up faster and it costs less money.
And the fact that some of that stuff is still in the meet your problem.
Wow.
So when you're getting pork chops are getting it cause they grain,
it all depends on who fed the pig.
Jesus Christ.
So when you're getting steak you're getting that.
If you're not eating grass fed steak,
you're making a mistake.
And that's one of the reasons you go on a Vegan Diet.
If you're eating really good quality,
non Moldy Vegan food,
you're going to get less toxins.
Like you compare a Vegan or vegetarian versus standard industrial meat based,
you know,
meat and hydrogenated fat and Msg Diet Man,
I would rather be a Vegan then a standard American diet any day of the week.
The problem is that if I want to
for many,
many years have the highest energy levels,
the most focused with the least amount of effort,
you're not going to be able to achieve that on the Vegan diet and I don't think
you'll hit your very top level of performance as a hundred percent Vegan.
You could probably be mostly Vegan,
but you're going to be missing out on some things over time.
Like there's pretty good research on my side about that.
This is,
it's,
it's unbelievable that you,
you sound so convincing,
but I'm too stupid to know if you're right.
There's a lot of convincing vegans out there too.
Yes,
there are.
Well,
you know there's a lot of people that tell you how much it changed their life,
but my point is with a lot of those peoples that generally,
there's not all,
but generally they come from a really bad diet and then they start eating your
vegetables and they feel better.
Well,
of course you're going to feel better,
but I think your point,
it really does make a lot of sense as to what is,
what is the optimum way to do it.
This is all stuff that I'd never heard before.
I'd never heard it all meet has some sort of low level Mike,
Michael,
Miko,
mycotoxins,
but it's the only industrial meat like the,
I have a half account in my fridge.
It grew up three miles from my house.
It costs $3 and 50 cents a pound and it's grass fed.
It never ate any grain.
It was well treated.
It was butchered humanely and it tastes awesome.
Like he's really good meat and I to do you have a big freezer?
Yeah,
just have a,
the cost 300 bucks at Costco.
It's not even that hard to do.
Just by the freezer,
toss it in the back of the car,
bring it home,
throw it in the basement and you've got meat that costs a third of what it's
going to cost or,
or 20% of what it would cost at whole foods.
I've got links on my site.
You can order a hundred pounds at a time and just have it shipped to your house.
Jesus Christ.
But doesn't it taste funky because it's frozen?
You know,
this is a funny thing about me.
When they hang meat to let it age,
what they're doing is they're letting basically mold and bacteria in the
environment like work on the meat.
Well the links between those molds and human health are not so good.
Think about it.
This is a mold that likes to eat meat and Joe,
you and me are made out of meat.
So the incidence of low level fungal infections,
like I don't need dry age meat.
That's cooked really rare cause they're still active fungus that likes to eat.
What I made out of in there,
I don't think that's good man.
How do I not know about it?
So I burned calories.
Joe Is this meat?
That's it.
You just snort,
snort and mold.
So it turns out you want the freshest of anything.
As soon as you kill it and you drain the blood,
throw it in the freezer and when you're ready to eat it,
take it out.
How many hours from the time it's killed,
butchered and then frozen.
The stuff that I have,
I actually specially requested it.
It was about two days.
Two days.
Yeah.
So they just meet laze around for two days.
What they do is they hang it in a climate controlled environment which lets all
the blood come out.
But typical like high end steak,
21 days,
sometimes up to like 64 days.
Dry Age.
Yeah.
And then you know,
drives me,
tastes amazing.
I'm not going to say that it's bad,
but the difference in how dry age meat makes your brain feel versus fresh meat
that's been frozen right away and then defrost it and cooked.
You will feel like a different human being when you eat that stuff.
What is killed during the freezing process?
Is there anything that's killed?
It's not about the killing,
although it can kill parasites like they use that in now you freeze a Sushi
for a while at very low temperatures to kill parasites.
What's going on is you're preventing the formation of these basically
psychoactive compounds that form in addition to those nice yummy flavors that
come from the east and the fungus sending tendrils into the meat.
So that nice kind of soft,
mushy,
dry age meat.
Even if it's grass fed,
it has health impacts including cardiovascular impacts that are not present for
fresh meat that was frozen.
Wow.
But yet so delicious.
Nature's fucked us again man.
I still eat bacon,
no problems there.
Here's the thing,
why?
Why does dry cause dry age does tastes pretty damn good.
It here's how we discovered dry a dry.
How long have we really had good freezers,
right?
Not that long.
And so you're going to kill a giant cow a hundred years ago.
You're going to hang it in the coolest place that you can find and you're going
to whack off pieces of an eat it like kind of cal on the cop,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
I mean back then there must have eaten a lot of rotten meat.
Just yeah,
keep it going.
Now did that have anything to do with the,
the appendix or was the appendix for processing fiber?
What was the appendix
processing?
I don't think that there's a scientific consensus there.
I've heard it.
It's a store for um,
uh,
for probiotics potentially like the healthy bacteria.
Like that's like the little storehouse for them,
but I've never heard a definitive,
this is why we had an appendix that everyone agreed with.
So humans for a long time had to be able to deal with a certain amount of fungus
and bacteria.
In fact,
wired magazine.
Yeah,
just published this whole thing like,
oh,
we've been focusing on the genome of the bacteria in the gut and we just noticed
there's just as much fungus growing in your gut as there is bacteria.
If we don't know anything about it,
she's as Christ.
How weird is it that we have organisms that are essential to human survival and
they live inside of our intestinal tract.
They're essential.
If you don't have them,
you will die.
The question is,
are they apart from,
I mean that's a part of being human,
right?
If you're dead without them,
they're just like party your repair system.
Yeah,
there the soldiers.
So the little soldiers,
that's what I,
when I tell people about probiotics,
I used to get sick a lot when I went on the road until I really started getting
into Kombucha is my favorite because it's easy.
I liked the way it tastes and I'll drink a couple of those a day and I'm
covered.
And it's made a huge significant impact on how many calls did I get.
I mean it's just they stopped,
they just stopped.
I love it.
And the way I explained to people,
I go,
it's like hell.
When you eat healthy bacteria,
it's like sending soldiers.
You have healthy soldiers,
they're going to go out and whack all the shitty things that you touch.
Like it really does work that,
yeah,
but now think about this.
If you do that,
do drink your Kombucha and then you go have a normal,
you know rabbi that was fed industrial meat.
It's got antibiotics and that means they use antibiotics cause they make animals
fatter,
faster so that it's not that they're using it to keep him from getting sick,
they just want the,
the muscle striations.
They want the fat to marble through the muscle.
So now you're eating that.
You just whacked those nice bacteria that you put in your gut.
And that's why I'm kind of militant when I go out.
I'll eat fish like non farmed fish,
wild caught fish long before I'm an eat steak at a normal steakhouse.
If they say,
oh it's fed grass finished
steak,
I'm like double load me up.
I'll have two pounds of it.
But the rest of the time when I'm on the road,
I'm,
you know,
you'll see in my backpack I've got,
smoke sockeye salmon.
That's stuff is as clean as it gets.
So when you go to a restaurant,
what were of still your EAD rather,
but it's hard to even get wild fish,
man.
A lot of fishes farmed fish like that weird salmon where they actually changed
the color of the,
the,
the flash to China.
That's not right.
When you hit these prison bitch salmon,
the ones that you buy in the supermarket,
they have like this pale flesh.
It's like they just like fuck it and it's mushy.
It's gross.
They feeding them pallets,
you know,
and the pellets are like soy and corn and antibiotics plus ground up sardines
and it's,
they're,
they're environmentally destructive.
Like you shouldn't buy farmed fish on principle because it's bad for the world.
Like our oceans are already screwed up enough.
We don't need that.
It's also like,
it seems fucked up.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's fucked up enough that you catch them with nets,
you know,
just swoop through an entire environment and kill everything and rope it up and
that's fucked up enough.
But at least those were wild,
wild until that moment.
And then they got checked.
But to just live in this fucking kitty pawn,
while they throw this bullshit and on top of you,
that's all you have to eat just seems fucking stupid.
I think w there's certain things that people do to animals that are really
arrogant and zoos are one of them.
Ah,
and I just kind of break my heart even though the real natural ones.
But I've been to zoos like in Cambodia and all and like you see the stress
behavior in animals,
it's,
it's just horrible.
It shouldn't be allowed.
It I,
I'm a hypocrite because I go cause I want my kids to see what animals look like
cause it's interesting.
But if I had my choice,
I would say don't let this bring you back to the woods,
man.
Let them live in the jungle at the liver.
They live.
This is nonsense.
Like you either you either want to get rid of them because they're dangerous or
you know,
leave them the fuck alone.
Those are those,
the two options,
the idea that you can take them and just lock them in this little environment so
people can stare at them as they paste in circles.
That's torture.
That's craziness.
And even let them kill anything and you know,
it's bad.
Look what they feed those animals.
They all die like in a third.
The amount of time they live in the wild and it's not just stress from being in
captivity and you're having people throw cigarette butts at you.
It's because they feed them crap and they're sort of figuring that out.
Oh look,
they keep dying and we keep having surgery and doing all this weird stuff to
keep them alive.
Kind of like they do for people now.
They're giving them prison food,
poor fucking gorillas.
So sad.
[inaudible] watched him pace around that thing.
I was like,
wow,
you know,
my two year old thinks it's awesome,
but you know,
to me it's,
it's,
it's kind of trippy eagles,
the eagles in this net,
the eagles couldn't fly.
It was crazy.
They get an Roi like a little bit and then land and fly a little bit and you're
like,
oh my God,
they must be going nuts.
They fucking bald eagles and they can't just sore.
Like they get sore man and float around and they want to like kill rabbits and
things like that.
I'm pretty sure they're not getting much of that going on even though pellets,
they're giving them dog shit.
And a can,
you know,
it's like,
it's terrible.
What are they feeding them?
They push out a little tray of meat and the Eagle eats.
It's ridiculous.
We were that we would take away the one thing that nature must have them set up
for a massive reward of endorphins and of of,
you know,
Sarah,
whatever the fuck their little brains produce a little lizard.
Excellent questions.
Evil Eyes.
You have a look in the eyes of an eagle.
What a creepy fucking eyeball.
Those things.
That Eagle is just representing our country very well.
Joe,
look,
Eagle fly.
If you ever heard that video where I'm that crazy dude that used John Ashcroft.
Remember John Ashbery?
Super Crazy.
Super Crazy,
but he has a song I remember.
Did we play on the podcast ones?
Yeah,
we won't play it again.
Just look up.
John Ashcroft.
Let the Eagle Soar.
Oh my God.
Or let the eagle fly.
What does it add?
Dubstep at the end of it's probably better.
It's,
it's,
it's amazingly crazy.
Have you seen it a long time ago?
Yeah.
It's amazingly crazy if she wants that sky diver.
Yes.
That was amazing.
Did you see that?
That's awesome.
I was hoping that a Ufo was going to snatch him out of the sky on his way down.
That was an awesome,
that faint because doesn't that something like,
you know,
like scaring a bunny rabbit that,
that just your body can't take falling from space.
You almost did.
He said he was spinning and he said that if he spent spun anymore he could pass
out and die.
And so he was like,
do I pull the rip cord and slow down and I hit the record and he said,
I'm just going to do it anyway.
He didn't pass out.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was flipping and then he leveled out somehow or another.
I don't know how he leveled out the flying squirrel thing.
Just oh yeah,
he uh,
it was really weird to watch them step off of it though.
That was really weird to be right behind them with the camera and watch them
just drop on a site.
That's pretty epic.
That dude was in a balloon.
I didn't know you could take a balloon.
The space that's your daycare.
Just know that know who'd want to take a balloon,
the space,
why haven't we done this already?
Why aren't their trips to go to space in a balloon?
Hi Richard Branson should check this guy out.
What's up rich?
And if you're right,
here's another question.
Is it possible you're hit by a satellite cause don't satellites whip around the
earth?
Sure.
It wouldn't be going like 500 miles an hour or something to get,
they're usually probably like not like states off,
you know like millions of miles off.
Like that almost hit me like I'm smelling satellites.
It's the space junk.
So we didn't talk about this but like I,
I'm a geek.
Like I,
I'm a vice president at a computer and that security company,
like Silicon Valley Guy and yeah,
we have like problems with space junk,
serious problems where they map it all out and there's like storms were like
little nuts from like a Chinese rocket from 40 years ago or whatever.
It was spinning around probably not 40 years.
And they're like bullets.
I mean there's,
there hypersonic and they poke holes in satellites.
They can kill people on space station,
so it's getting to be like,
my God,
it's kind of dangerous up there.
Jesus Christ.
Could you imagine sitting in the fucking space day shooting?
You hear like bolts?
Yeah,
you're digging and you're like,
that's the whole cash is a hole right to the other side and you look down,
your leg is bleeding.
They track all that stuff now so they know if it's coming.
Oh my God,
they tracked the bolts that are flying in space
because of how many of them are there?
Like hundreds of thousands now.
Oh my God.
Do you have like whole like you know,
leftover fueled capsules and all this stuff?
I astronauts poop that.
They do.
I'm serious.
Like frozen.
You know things they'd like to buy it.
Frozen Turd and when you're out on a space walk,
if it can happen.
I've had semi frozen Turd Beam Debbie and it still hurt.
I can't believe that.
I can't believe there's hundreds of thousands of pieces of junk up there.
That's insane.
Yeah.
No one's going to clean that either.
It's not like you can put a net up there and scoop it all up because for most of
it came from military exercises.
Let's blow up a satellite in orbit and see what happens.
Like,
oh,
it scatters crap all over orbit.
Yeah,
it's just an environmental problem.
Just like we have in our oceans are somewhere else in the middle.
Sir.
So crazy that in the 60s when they first started like thinking about going to
the moon,
they did the thing called
[inaudible] starfish prime,
where they shot a nuclear bomb up into the atmosphere and blew it up.
They blew it up in the radiation belts.
Just let's see what happened and what will happen though.
It's fucking crazy.
Nobody knows.
There's no money.
They had to go,
hey,
what are you doing?
Don't just fucking do it to see what happens.
You guys crazy.
What's the benefit of shooting a nuclear bomb in this space?
You crazy fucks theirs.
They've gotten nuts on that stuff.
It's interesting.
My grandparents met on the Manhattan project like in Chicago before Los
Homeless.
My grandmother's a master's degree in nuclear engineering in one like a lifetime
achievement reward for nuclear engineering,
like one of two women ever.
So like I grew up in a nuclear family like this,
but even there like could we stop blowing those things up everywhere?
Like they're kind of useful in a war,
but like maybe blowing up a few hundred of them around the planet isn't a good
idea.
Well,
have you ever seen the A,
there's an animated Gif file or maybe it's a video that shows all of the,
on the globe shows you a map of the world and it shows all of the nuclear
explosions in their correct order that have taken place,
all the tests and it's like
boom,
boom.
And the Soviet Union ones pump,
pump,
pump.
Wow.
Want to be awesome.
You should link to that
video
of all of the nuclear explosion.
It's just to try,
you'll,
you'll find it.
Um,
but I've seen it,
it's fast.
There's been like more than a hundred.
Yeah.
A hundred nuclear explosions.
I did not know that.
It's really scary.
And some of the things that happen there.
We have a kind of a rise in thyroid cancer and gee,
you get radioactive iodine out there and have these having environmental impact.
And some of the stuff we don't even understand like low frequency vibrations on
the Earth's crust from those things.
There's biological effects from the reverberation of the Earth's crust here to
the Schuman residence.
Um,
when funders strikes,
you get this reflection between the eye on the sphere and the earth's crust and
it creates a,
uh,
basically a,
a brown to 10 hearts.
I forget the nine point something hertz frequency.
And if we don't have this,
like we don't work very well as humans.
And in fact,
in the Russian space program,
they actually figured out that they were not doing well at all.
They actually replicate this inside the spacecraft.
Now make a rumble or go sound,
you don't hear it.
It's like an electrical thing.
It's a super low frequency EMF.
So this,
this EMF that's given out by thunder and lightening is actually actually has a
positive effect on human beings.
It's like a timing signal.
If we don't get it,
we don't do so well.
It's right in the Alpha brainwave spectrum.
Oh yeah.
In fact,
I have a human way of residence,
uh,
creation thing in my,
in my house.
Like it's one of things that lowers biological stress.
When you have a Schumann resonance that you're low level biological,
like electrical systems can sync to,
it lowers the stress.
If you have like Wifi routers and things like that all over the place,
your body tries to like find a signal and it doesn't get one very well.
And when it doesn't get one very well,
it just raises your cortisol levels.
Your body is trying to find a signal.
What do you mean by that?
So there's an electromagnetic signal on the earth and it sounds kind of goofy to
be honest,
but one of the ways you can do this is with an earthing mat.
And I kind of went out on a limb and I started promoting these as like this,
this thing rocks.
And what this is,
is,
is a mat.
It's made out of electrically conductive fibers.
It's just silver woven into a sheet and you plug it into the round part of the
electrical outlet at your house.
So just the grounding part.
Are you sticking into the earth,
like drop it out the window on a wire and stick it into the ground?
You do this and it normalizes your quarters logs Grecian at night,
your sleep improves really dramatically.
Especially for jet lag.
I absolutely will not travel without my earthing mat because I don't get jet lag
at all anymore.
Like it's just a nonissue what craziness.
Lance Armstrong uses this on the Tour de France in order to recover faster,
like you recover from injuries faster when you're grounded and there's an
electrical thing,
you can measure this happening there.
There's two effects.
One is you build up a charge on your body and you can just pick this up with a
meter.
You were walking around indoors or wearing shoes like rubber shoes all the time.
So we basically just the error over our skin builds up a static charge.
When you get a spark,
you know,
like in the desert,
you know you touched the most static electricity.
That's an extreme example of it,
but our bodies kind of work like big batteries,
like we have different electrical fields in different electrical potentials
inside the body.
So when you spend about 20 minutes walking in grass barefoot or laying on
earthing mats being on the beach,
what you're doing is you're dropping the extra charge that's built up over time.
And when you do that,
you heal faster.
You really do recover faster.
It,
it's profoundly amazing how well it works.
Um,
there's cardiologist's recommending this,
there's a whole book written about this.
I'm like,
I've heard about people lying in the grass sleeping in the grass.
That's why to help them heal.
I thought this was such bs,
but like I used to fly to Cambridge,
England every six weeks.
I was a vice president of the company based out there and I'd fly from,
from the bay area out there.
And that's like the worst commute ever in terms of time zones,
like you're flying east.
And I would go and I'd start in the morning when I land,
I'm going to exercise to raise my body temperature and that's going to be how I
hacked my jet,
my jet lag.
And one day I did yoga in the park because like the only day of the year it was
not rainy in England.
And uh,
that's how I had no jet lag.
I'm like,
yes,
my exercise works.
Then the next time I do it in hotel rooms,
the same exact thing and had horrible jet lag.
I'm like,
what is it?
And I finally like,
like understood years later what,
what had really been the variable that I didn't know to look for.
So this is one of the things,
it's like a $70 little item and you try it and you just know it works.
I wish marijuana was legal to grow cause I went to a grow room once in this dude
had this,
uh,
he was illegal.
It was illegal set up.
I go into the back room and he's got this room larger than this room and it's
filled with these really happy cannabis plants.
And they have there have been taken care of with the perfect fertilizer and the
perfect soil composition.
There's misters or going off constantly and there were really healthy and
vibrant and you walk into that room and you feel them and it sounds like hippie
bullshit,
but I wasn't even high.
I walked in that room stone cold sober and I was like,
Whoa,
this,
this is like,
like they have a frequency.
Like there's like it's an intangible thing that I sense,
I can feel it but I wouldn't know how to describe what it's doing.
I do a lot of work at that level with the biohacking I talk about.
So you have this reptilian brain that's responsible for low level systems in the
body.
It's the same thing as salamander has and it census stuff,
but it does it so fast that you don't even know what happened.
Like if you put your hand on a hot stove,
you'll pull your hand away before you know the stove was hot.
And that's an example of this thing in action.
So what it does is it picks up all kinds of stuff from the environment.
A lot of stuff we don't even understand yet,
but it does it and it matches patterns so fast that you might just get like a
wisp of an intuition from it.
But what's going on there is like the,
the animal part of you is totally picking up all these things and you can train
yourself to,
to basically be more sensitive to what it,
what it's telling you and you can train yourself and train it to behave better
because that reptilian brain is what gets us in a lot of trouble.
It's all how you know when someone's upset at you,
when someone's upset at you,
even if they're trying to pretend that they're not,
you know,
there's somethings off that giving you a certain feel.
Now I'm going to sound like a total hippie Wacko.
It's,
which I'm not too late at.
Darn.
So you're on this show.
I'll take that.
So I'm an advisor to this company called the heart math institute and heart math
makes a heart rate variability training device.
These guys are Silicon Valley geeks.
They spent 20 years looking at like meditation and how you quantify meditation,
like what's going on in the body.
And it turns out by looking at the spacing between your heartbeats,
you can totally change the way your brain works in the way your body works.
And in the course of their research,
they went out and they did some really heavy duty science and there's actually a
magnetic field around your heart.
It's tipped it like a 12 degree angle way.
It's shaped like a tourist,
like a donut.
And they know which direction the fields,
uh,
move on it and everything.
So it's the most electrically active part of your bodies.
You're hired and get this.
When a human walks into a stall with a horse,
before they touched the horse,
the horse is heart rate variability will change to match the humans.
We have a field of fact on the people around us and it's an electromagnetic
field that's heart-based and like we can measure it and people get pissed off
when they hear this and then they just think everything I say is crap.
It's not like a,
I know the scientists who are behind this and B,
I'm a certified heart math executive coach.
Like I use this to take people who are super high performers who are tweaking
because of their stress and to teach them to consciously basically use their
prefrontal cortex.
They're human most evolved part of the brain to to train and take control of the
reptilian brain and when you do that there's measurable changes in the spacing
of your heartbeats and there's a change in the field or on your heart as well.
When you do that,
that's what you're,
that's what you're feeling there.
Someone's pissed off at you.
They could not say a word and you might not even see their face when you just
have a feeling.
We also know Bobby is letting you know some shit might be going down.
I'm catching something bad smells and in fact one of my,
one of my buddies is a special forces guy and he actually wasn't technically
trained special forces guys.
He was a long range patrol officer guy and he told me one day,
he said,
Dave,
what we learned out in the field,
he said,
if you're in someone's sites,
you can feel it.
He said,
if someone's got a gun pointed at you like you're,
your body heats up.
Like,
like literally how the heck could this be possible?
But the bottom line is we have all sorts of weird senses.
We also know if we hook you up Joe to like weird galvanic skin response sensors
and then you're sitting there if someone's staring at you will be able to
measure your body responding to the stair even if they're staring at your back.
Like there's all kinds of crazy stuff in our bodies we haven't even really
explored yet.
Do you think those are evolving senses or do you think those are just like
really sort of intangible senses that we haven't quite defined?
They're not evolving senses.
Their old senses.
Those were there long before.
You know what?
What makes the the frog move before the Eagle John,
before the eagle dives for it,
right.
It's those kinds of senses.
It's a very,
very low level survival oriented census.
Um,
you sure they're not evolving,
they're not getting better.
Maybe.
I think what's happening is that our ability to access them from our prefrontal
cortex is evolving.
And that's one of the things I spend a lot of my own time on.
I spent $20,000 and seven days hooked up to an EEG machine to learn how to do
like advanced zen meditation.
That takes 40 years.
I didn't seven days.
And what you're really doing there is you're just learning how to have the
prefrontal Cortex,
your human brain talk to the low level systems.
And when you do that,
like you can unleash creativity and intelligence and intuition in ways that,
you know,
most people aren't that familiar with.
What do you think is going on when you see people that are our kids usually that
are autistic but they're super genius in one area.
Like there was one kid that was making,
uh,
he was composing a symphony every nine days or something like that and they were
really good.
It was really good music.
And then there's a kid who can look out a window and out of an airplane and the
entire skyline
as he sees it perfectly.
Like do you think that that's evolving possibilities in the brain that are just
starting to sort of pop up?
I don't.
You don't.
And I say that I had all the symptoms of Asperger's syndrome till I was in my
mid twenties like obsessive compulsive disorder,
oppositional defiant disorder.
I didn't know anyone's name,
like I wouldn't make eye contact,
all that kind of stuff.
I stuttered a little bit and I've done a lot of work with the autism community.
In fact,
one of my goals in this book that I'm writing to the better baby book that comes
out in January is to have less kids with autism because you can handle
neurological inflammation even in the womb,
so there's less likelihood of it happening later.
What we can do though is we can take a fully functioning neurologically
functioning adult and we can hit them with really strong magnets in their head
and we can turn on autistic skills and non autistic people.
So you can suddenly draw the most amazing thing ever when you have a 10 ton
magnet focused on your head.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
So this is some serious brain hacking stuff like that fucking dude from the
expert and that magneto dude,
I hadn't thought of it like that.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it is.
It is Hema goddamn genius with that magnet helmet on member.
Yeah.
And they're doing this like in a,
uh,
in neuroscience laboratories right now.
Like they have this really focused thing that that shines a magnet and it
activates a specific part of your brain.
You can even do it to some extent with the stuff having my backpack,
like a cerebral electrical stimulation or tdcs,
you can run a current through part of your brain and turned it on.
It wasn't turned on before and as long as there's electricity there,
it's turned on.
So I think what's going on here is the wiring and autistic kids,
they have chronic neurological inflammation that's environmentally mediated and
these you have problems with the biology and their gut too.
So what we can do though is we can learn,
okay,
these autistic kids have these skills.
All of us have these skills too.
They're just not trained and they're not turned on.
If you use technology,
you can train your brain to do crazy stuff in very short periods of time so you
can gain these kind of powers without having to give up the ability to socialize
for instance.
But a kid looking out a window and and being able to capture the exact skyline
and then put that to paper as he,
you know,
I don't know if these are classically trained artist.
I think he just does it.
That is a really special skill.
It's a special skill,
but I'll bet you that if we took six months and we use those magnets and things
like that,
we can,
we can explore how his brain works and teach your brain to do the same thing.
There's a lot of things out there that are way teachable that you wouldn't think
are,
it's all just about interfacing with the brain.
And the way we do it now is really inefficient.
If I have a gigantic magnet on my head,
boy,
I played better pool.
Uh,
I think it depends on how much the magnet weight is probably,
well,
I mean,
as far as like the frequent,
it needs something,
it's not something you'd wear.
It's not something you're wearing this little bit.
Laceless.
When I say 10 tons,
I mean like this is a 10 ton thing that that changes it.
And there's various like articles from neuroscientist,
they went in,
they did the test and they drew like the most amazing artwork.
Uh,
or in the military they do other things like that with more with electricity.
But they'll say,
oh look,
this person got a stimulation here.
And they went through the shooting simulation and they killed everyone
completely.
Whereas the last time they had no skills at all real.
Oh yeah.
So like your brain is like such an amazing toy.
You can completely change it.
But here's the thing you want,
you want to maximize this performance.
You need to myelinate the nerves in your brain.
Myelination makes a nerve carry electrical signals 3000 times faster than a non
myelinated nerve.
So first you have to form the synapse apps,
which is called synaptic genesis.
And you do that through relatively short amounts of practice.
You know,
the first time you learned,
well,
the first time you learned to balance on your bike,
right?
Like you've,
you've learned how to do it.
It doesn't take long from then on though to get it.
So it's just automatic.
That's what repetition does.
And you've had a lot of pro sports guys and here they talking about 10,000 times
and repetitions.
The reason 10,000 times works is because you're myelinating.
But here's the thing,
what's my island made out of?
Fat,
cholesterol,
Coleen.
So what you need to do is you need to be cranking up on those kinds of foods.
And if you're going to be on a low fat or a Vegan Diet that doesn't have any of
the saturated fats and as low and Coleen,
you're probably gonna have a harder time myelinating.
It's gonna be harder for your brain to do what it was meant to do.
So synaptic speaking,
it's harder to learn things.
Yup.
If you don't have enough fat,
you've got to have fat for your brain to function.
I mean,
your brain is made out of fat,
but you don't want the wrong fat.
You don't want fat from a stupid cow that ate corn.
No,
you're done.
You're all stupid.
Yeah.
And you don't want fat that's been impregnated with toxins.
So you got to have grass fed meat.
You got to have it from some sort of a reputable source where you know that
they're not feeding the any antibiotics.
How do you put the magnets on the cows,
Joe?
That's awesome.
I blew my fucking mind.
Yes.
Magnet Fed beef.
It's the cows started walking up to the fence going,
I think we can get through it.
We just knock one of these fucking things over.
The magneto helmet with the horns on it to match of cows started figuring out
that it just fuck us up.
The corn just grows there.
Just let it grow.
It will grow by itself.
I found that video.
If you wanted to watch the nuclear explosion.
Yes.
Yeah.
Let's see this.
This is crazy,
Matt.
This is,
by the way,
just America.
There's one of the world.
Oh,
this is the whole world.
here it goes here.
See how it'd be like soccer,
soccer.
Hiroshima.
Yeah.
This is so creepy.
We're so nuts.
Here's a crazy statistic that we figured out in a podcast from the invention of
the airplane to someone using it to drop a nuclear bomb on someone took less
than 50 years.
That's pretty impressive.
That's insane.
Wow.
Think about that as like a world changing.
Yeah.
It makes Moore's law look kind of sissy.
That's pretty amazing.
You know,
50 years later,
the dropping nuclear bombs out of them.
Russia starts jacking some off.
Fair.
Boom son.
There we go.
It starts just getting crazier and crazier after this.
Right now we're up to eight from America.
One from Russia,
so not the sound of
how long has video
cause for the folks at homeless,
18 minutes of explosions,
but a lot of them were in,
there's a lot of Soviet Union.
Look at all those ones in Nevada.
It just goes crazy.
Nevada just lights up like a Christmas tree.
They were all in Nevada.
All Nevada,
Britain.
How dare you?
Sons of bitches in the ocean.
Yeah,
you cowards.
But I'm in the ocean.
Look at Nevada.
Oh my God.
So scary.
They're all Nevada and explains Nevada,
doesn't it?
Fuck yeah.
Does Las Vegas right there?
It explains the reason why it's allowed to exist.
I mean they do nuclear tests,
explains the airport.
They also bury a,
they bury a lot of nuclear waste out there and not in Vegas,
but and look at Russia.
It's still glowing.
Scary shit man.
Oh my God.
More Devonta look at that.
And that's something 1955 looking at how many of them are going off in Nevada
that is fucking bananas.
And compare that to like the recent a nuclear reactor leak in Japan.
I don't know if this might be worse.
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
I don't know which one lasts more.
Yeah,
that was pretty brutal.
But they also have shit buried out there too.
They're storing nuclear waste out there.
Yeah.
Spent nuclear rods and all kinds of other shit that they think will be toxic to
the end of time.
We're just so ridiculous.
It's just so weird that we would have something like that and just fucking start
look at this.
Wow.
It's kind of sounds like music.
Look how many
balms have gone off.
300 moms
and we're still in the 1960 like we haven't even gotten into the mind.
It's a 1959 and there's been 300 bombs.
Wow.
This is really hard to watch,
but no kidding.
Total down here.
They were so stupid back.
Do you have any Justin Bieber videos we can watch and stuff?
Yeah,
I think we should kill that.
Brian,
what are you concerned about?
Like the toxic shit that's going to happen from Fukushima.
Is that going to affect people that live here on the west coast?
Yeah,
it is.
I mean the,
the plume,
so to speak,
is making its way over here.
Now what does that mean?
We're actually finding a huge amounts of wreckage that are hitting the shore
now.
In fact,
up where I live in British Columbia,
like it,
it's a big thing.
They're finding like motorcycles and something like hundred ton,
like cement docs that sort of walks wash up and like,
how do I get rid of this?
Like it's indestructible.
Oh my God.
A cement fucking doc that was taken from Japan.
Yeah,
it broke free and it floated all the way over here and it's like on the beach.
What's amazing is that it's a little baby tsunami.
That ain't shit compared to what could happen.
Oh yeah.
So that's happening.
But they say that the stuff that's radioactive hasn't reached there yet.
So they're starting to,
they're starting to have a Geiger counters on the beach,
like for the drunk cleanup crews to see if they're finding this stuff.
So the question is,
what's it going to do to fish out here?
I show up at my sockeye salmon is radioactive free.
And that said,
you know,
I,
I think taking iodine iodine is a good idea.
I do that.
How does potassium iodine protect you?
Well,
if the form of radioactivity that you're getting is radioactive iodine,
it protects you from getting thyroid cancer years later.
The problem is that some of the radioactive stuff coming out,
Fukushima may not be in an,
I died for him.
So I had,
I may not do much for you.
There's some evidence that asked us Anthon which comes from Krill is pretty
protective as well.
So that's probably a good thing to take.
So krill Krill oil,
should you take it in that form?
I prefer Krill oil to fish oil.
I take Krill oil and I put,
uh,
and since I put,
I buy a form that has asked as Anthony [inaudible],
which naturally occurs in the Krill,
it's the stuff that makes krill red.
It's just a really potent antioxidant that has a good effect on radioactive
stuff.
This is a podcast that is going to test your writing Shit Down Abilities Ladies
and gentlemen,
because this is a plug guys,
we're going to have to go back [inaudible] assault by the way.
Jakks salts 11 it'll make Yag salt.
You Liar.
You're a fucking fibber.
How dare you.
Yeah,
I've got to get,
I'm going to go right to full wholefoods right from here and get some fucking
Siberian salt or Tibetans salt.
Either one's good.
It tastes pretty good.
Like I like taking friends who are not into health and you're like,
just try this salt and not quite,
you carry white vial of powder over international borders with you.
Yeah.
Do you ever get tweaked on never.
It's weird.
I,
I mean I have like my upgraded whey protein and collagen powder and like all
kinds of stuff that I should look like I'm carrying kilos of random stuff.
But no one ever thought to ask you to trust it or they never actually one time
I've had my whey protein tested more often.
They checked my coffee cause I don't drink hotel coffee.
It makes me feel crappy.
I just,
my coffee.
So I bring it with me just like,
you know,
beans or ground up coffee every time that,
oh,
what's that?
And then they open it and they seems like they just want to smell it maybe,
I don't know.
Well it is that also the people how drugs and coffee.
It's the easiest way because it does,
it stops the dogs from smelling the marijuana.
You know,
it's funny,
I have a little a heard we've heard,
I have a little canister,
I put it in there that that's got a desk again that like absorbs moisture.
So I mean it looks like I've got a little,
a little canister of drugs inside my coffee and twice I've had people say what's
in there and like keeps the coffee dry and they,
they just don't stop me.
And I fly like a hundred times a year,
like very often.
Wow.
I drink a Trenta of coffee every single day and then,
then I eat my first meal about eight o'clock at night.
Nice.
That,
does it seem like,
I used to put butter in my coffee now?
Is that what you would recommend?
I would try it.
I seriously,
what if you're eating nothing else?
Yeah,
yeah.
I would try just some fat,
no sugar,
no protein,
but when you do that,
even just a tablespoon,
you may find that you have a lot more energy throughout the day and splinters.
Okay,
like artificial sugar or just stay away from it.
Just do Stevia if you're going to do anything.
Yeah,
you can do is,
I will talk to a little bit was that a tall won't raise your own,
stolen enough to matter,
but if you do a lot of Xylitol and you're not used to it,
you'll get the runs like you'll take made the bulletproof coffee with Stevia and
it was fucking delicious.
What was addicted to it?
It's really good,
but the problem is you're a lazy bitch and you're not going to,
let's be honest,
you're not going to fucking get some grass fed butter and melted and blend it.
You don't have to melt it and just like toss the butter in the blender,
pour the hot coffee right in there and hit blend for 2030 slave.
I may do that.
Needed to get one of you.
I'll get butter,
get Yulia butter and you can get sent to your oil to you.
You know you could get groceries now just delivered to your house.
It's amazing.
And it's not that much money.
Like you just go online and pick out what you want and then it's just like,
all right,
we'll see you on an hour.
Like a pizza.
That's pretty sweet.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's amazing.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
And plus butter keeps forever.
You can buy like 20 sticks of it and toss it in the freezer and you'll have
butter coming out your eyes like so you,
you want to make sure when you go to like organically raised beef is not good
enough.
It has to be grass fed,
organically raised.
You can take organic corn,
organic soil and organic Twinkies and feed them to an organic cow and still sell
it as organic meat.
Like the standards are pretty low.
We keep,
Twinkies can be organic.
If they make one,
you can feed it to an organic cow and it's still organic.
There's no standards for what the cows eat.
It's just whether or not what they ate was sprayed.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
Um,
so but so for a lot of folks it's kind of difficult to find grass fed meat in
your area.
Isn't it like a lot of traditional supermarkets?
It is.
If you're,
you know,
in the middle of nowhere.
But here's the thing,
like Fedex and ups deliver everywhere.
It's cheaper to buy grass fed meat online than it is to buy like a decent cut of
meat in a grocery store.
Like if you're going to buy grass fed hamburger from some of the best places on
earth,
like I've like tested different places on my site.
Like I have a whole series is about grass fed beef.
You can get it for five bucks a pound,
like for grass fed,
perfectly treated animals.
Wow.
That's fucking really good.
Yeah.
And so like,
even if you're on a budget,
like okay,
eat a lot of eggs because they're cheap and you know,
supplement with grass fed beef,
you had a half a pound a day,
it's going to cost you $2 and 50 cents.
Do you ever buy just fat?
Do you say like,
send me some fat.
I've bought beef tallow.
The problem is what's called,
yeah,
it's beef towels just rendered beef fat.
The problem is that the rendering process is really finicky plus 15 finicky.
Well,
if you're going to render fat,
you need to have enough water in it in order to render it so it doesn't oxidize.
One of the problems,
especially in the Paleo community,
and it drives me nuts.
People like Bacon,
like,
okay,
I love my bacon.
I'm a bacon snob.
I like,
I make my own bacon.
But what you've,
you've got to do though is not overcook the oils.
If you,
if it's spitting all over the place and there's smoke coming off the pan and
you're Bacon's crispy,
you've oxidized the fat.
And one of the things on the bulletproof diet and I'm really focused on is like,
how do I get inflammation down?
So if you fry the crap out of your food,
then what you're getting is inflammatory oils.
Even if they came from a good cow,
you're also getting delicious baked in.
That's a problem.
You're getting delicious bacon.
But here's the thing,
you put your stove on like three or four and you cook the Bacon for longer.
All the fat melts out of the Bacon.
The Bacon does not going to get all super crispy,
but it's a chewier begging,
right?
It's,
it's a little chewier but it's not like,
like bad.
She'll be like uncooked bacon still awesome.
I like chewy big,
but I'll do like that fucked up crispy Bacon Bacon.
It totally.
And like,
it's like we have like fried
Mozzarella too,
but like,
and he got to like choose where you go on the spectrum.
What is it about fried things?
It's so horrible for you.
What does it do to your body?
It's mostly the damage fats.
They come in and your body's just like,
what do I do with this?
Fat?
Just can't process it because it's overcooked.
Yeah.
It's like,
how do I,
how do I detoxify this?
So it's basically spitting out free radicals and then you try and build cell
walls and hormones out of this fat and your body.
Just like I do,
I do that.
I don't have the raw ingredients.
Why is it so fucking delicious that I would love to know.
I think what?
What happens there for real,
right?
Like Kentucky Fried Chicken.
God Damn.
Well that Shit's good.
That's MSG and gluten and stuff ever.
It is.
I like it.
Yeah.
It was really MSG in gluten.
Oh Geez.
In like everything.
You know what?
It's God damn wonderful.
Don't change a thing.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
We won't even talk about Msg and obesity after that.
Yeah.
Well let's talk about how to think about food in general,
whether it's Vegan or not.
Cause Google,
please explain though.
What did what,
what it does when your body takes in a,
just like Kentucky Fried Chicken or anything.
Some of it's hydrogenated oil,
fried French fries and chips.
So we don't make healthy cell walls or hormones or anything else in our body
made out of fat.
We didn't even burn hydrogenated fat very well for,
uh,
for fuel.
So it basically is,
the liver has to detoxify it.
So it goes to the liver.
Liver was like,
Oh God,
what I do with this stuff.
So it starts using up the glutathione in your liver,
which is the main detoxing enzyme.
It starts trying to figure out how to break down these oils,
like were designed to take basically a raw animal in and process it and to break
all those fats down into reassemble them into our body.
We're not,
we're not meant to take those things in.
So what you get is actually a big rush of white blood cells when you eat like
heavily cooked meat and the oxidized fried fats and it actually,
it looks like an immune response and your body's like,
okay,
I gotta do something about this.
So it does what it can to build healthy cell walls,
but you get hungry after you eat fried food.
If you ever noticed that,
like you feel full for well and afterwards like I want like sugar or something,
the craving that you want for sugar,
they're either comes from the MSG or it comes from your livers.
Like could I have some more fuel to use to oxidize this stuff so I can excrete
it now instead of building it in?
Wow.
I never noticed that.
I usually feel like it's such a fat loser.
Oh yeah.
So you don't get like hungry like your next meal.
You're like,
I don't like random cravings.
Okay,
cool.
Myself off I chicken.
Yeah,
but,
but I do like it like,
you know,
when I like it,
I like it like cold with hot sauce,
like watching stupid,
something stupid on TV.
It's a good snack.
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
you know the stuff tastes good.
I don't eat that stuff anymore.
I'm a delicate flower I guess cause I weighed 300 pounds.
I just feel like crap.
I need it now.
Yeah.
I feel like crap when I needed to,
but I don't feel like crap while I'm eating it.
That's the problem.
That's a fight while I'm eating it.
I'm loving it.
I'm loving the crispy outside mixed with the hot sauce.
So if they had Kentucky Fried Kale,
would you try that?
My,
he kale all the time.
I mean I would do,
I eat kale chips.
I bike.
A lot of Kale chips have been eaten those lately for snacks,
but I don't know what they're the cheese out of.
You know the cause.
It's some weird Vegan.
It's usually new use.
It's usually a nutritional yeast,
which is,
I don't even want to talk about what that does to your health.
Bad.
Yeah,
it's bad.
God dammit.
So fucking Kale chips are bad.
Nosy Kale chips don't have to be bad.
It's just what they used to make him cheesy.
[inaudible] motherfuckers so cheesy.
Kale chips or bad.
If they're using vinegar to make the cheesy flavor,
they're fine,
but most of them,
they use nutritional yeast and they see what I could.
I have so many studies about how come I knew they tasted too fucking good.
Yeah,
I knew it while,
sorry man.
These cheesy Kale chips are wonderful.
Why do you think they're so addictive and you're like,
ah,
yeah,
you fucking God dammit Vegan people.
How dare you?
How dare you get me to eat your shit that's bad for you,
but yet delicious.
There's going to be a huge storm on Twitter about people saying nutritional
yeast has B vitamins.
And I'm like,
yeah,
and look at the,
just go to pub med and Google cancer and nutritional yeast and see what you
find.
So the cheese is not a cheap,
it's actually a clump of organisms.
That's what the yeast is.
Yup.
It's like a,
it's like bakers and brewer's yeast.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then how they make it like a cheese,
they just,
well you actually kind of has a cheesy flavor on its own.
So they take that and they mix it with some other,
usually like a nut,
like a ricotta,
like or like a Vegan ricotta thing.
I mean I've been like,
uh,
I still eat a lot of like vegan dishes just under the weird soy and crap.
Like if it's made out of raw vegetables chopped up finally with enough good fat
in them,
like Avocados and some of the healthier food out there.
Right.
So I'm,
I'm a pretty good in the kitchen,
like with raw food.
And the problem is you add nutritional yeast to it,
it makes it inflammatory.
It's just not very good for him.
So that's just those kale chips.
You can get the regular Kale chips,
but that aren't quite as God damn delicious.
I'm sorry Joe Mother fuckers.
I knew,
I knew it couldn't have possibly die from cheesy Kale chips.
You're not concentrating on the time maximizing your potential.
That's why I think this is so far on the spectrum,
like,
okay,
if you ate cheesy Kale chips every day for the rest of your life compared to
potato chips,
you,
you fucking rocked it.
Okay.
That's why everything on the bulletproof diet is a spectrum.
It's like this is better than this,
but like this is a lot better than this,
so you don't have to be perfect.
If you,
you know,
if you want to identify a goalpost for perfection,
just kind of move in that direction and you'll be way better off.
And most people fail in their diets because they feel like,
oh I,
I did it wrong.
Now I lose.
I'm like,
you didn't do it wrong.
You could have done a lot worse.
You could have done it better,
but like you're somewhere in the middle.
And the truth of the matter is,
I'm always in the middle too.
Like,
okay,
I had a grass fed cow but you know,
was it slaughtered by you know,
an ordained minister.
I fail if I know,
but like,
like there's probably some way of making it slightly more perfect.
It wasn't massage every day.
I wouldn't want a minister to kill my cow.
I don't know if I went to dummy.
I actually tend to lose count agree with you.
Like I don't know if I don't like how blessed by the church,
bless it before you eat it,
but there has to be like some bizarre thing you could do that's better.
Like then again,
if someone really believed in the blessing,
maybe they would impart some sort of an energy into the thing.
That sounds ridiculous.
But what we were talking about before about people literally having some sort of
an environmental effect,
some sort of an effect on all the people around them.
How these,
look,
you
don't want some asshole killing your cow.
I'll tell you flat out,
I do not want a cow that was tortured before it was ill.
It changes the hormones at all?
I think it changes the taste and there's an energy thing there.
I mean,
call me a psycho hippie or whatever,
but I've done a lot of intuitive like training of my,
my,
my heart and of other parts of my body with electronics and like,
I dunno,
there's something not right about like,
you know,
some statistic asshole,
torturing your cow,
killing it and then feeding it to you.
Like it's face,
it's wrong.
Well it is.
And have you ever seen the way they do kosher cows?
Oh,
it's brutal.
It's those machines then.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's supposed to be done by a rabbi.
It's supposed to be done by a rabbi.
Rabbi supposed to slice the neck of the cow,
but you're,
you're supposed to do it that way.
That's how he killed a cow.
You slice his neck and it takes a while for him to die and it's not fucking
pretty.
And there's videos of them trying to get up and falling down and trying to get
up.
And you should see the kosher machines.
They do have kosher machine as long as it's,
as long as it lasts,
as long as it's been blessed.
That gets approved for kosher,
but it's even worse because it's like,
like the cows go in and they just like rip their throat out with like a raw and
it's,
it's one of the things where people think that,
oh,
you know,
Dave is the opposite of Vegan.
I'm like,
no,
I care a lot about the quality of the animals I eat and the quality of the food
I eat.
But I also care about the quality of my life and wanting to do with it.
And if I'm slowing myself down by eating inappropriate foods.
There's also another thing we've got to talk about,
talking about animal suffering.
I'm in Tibet,
right?
I spend like a couple months,
actually three months walking around Asia visiting monasteries and stuff and I
went to this monster.
I had the Vegan vegetarian diet for um,
she was Vegan for like 10 days.
I'm farting like a machine the whole time.
And then afterwards they go to another monastery in Lhasa and there's this giant
Yak skin on the prayer pole in the middle of the monastery.
And so I asked the head Lama Guy,
and I said,
okay,
like you're a hypocrite.
Like you'd say,
no killing,
and you've got a dead animal hanging on your prayer pole,
like what's the deal?
And he just looked at me and he,
you know,
the way like Buddhist monks kind of do,
we just kind of laughed and he said,
oh,
one death feeds everyone.
And then you walked away.
Like that was his whole thing.
And I thought about that.
If I eat two pounds of grass fed beef every day for a year,
I killed 0.7 animals in the entire food chain.
If I'm Vegan and I eat soy nuggets,
every bowl of soy nuggets is killing hundreds of animals because the tractor
goes through and cuts down the soil.
The soil,
not,
we're not even talking about what it did to the soil microbes,
but it cuts down all the soil.
It chops up the bunnies and their cute little faces and the turtles.
And the grasshoppers and the worms and all the other stuff there and basically
you look at the number of animals killed to bring you a bowl of grain.
It's way in excess of what grass fed beef does.
The vegan argument is,
well there's enough grass fed beef for everyone and I'm like,
yeah,
that's because people don't ask for it.
You asked for it.
We'll turn the golf courses into basically grass fed beef manufacturing plants.
There's plenty of them out there to do that.
By the way,
like there's people who've done the math.
It would be a B,
it would be a smaller cow.
You wouldn't have nearly as much fat and the taste is different.
The taste is different and this is Rogan doesn't like the grass fed beef.
I try to cook the grass fit man.
Taste tea.
Can we just say this podcast is grass fed now by how many grass fed is in it?
Yeah,
it just matters.
It's stamped.
I would eat a bowl of gravel if,
if I could perform.
I want it like I have real dogma about this.
Like,
I don't,
I don't care like food.
For me it's like optimal fuel for human potential.
That's it.
Not just delicious as well.
I mean,
I love the deliciousness.
I have a cookbook out for God's sake.
Oh deal.
It's called the upgraded chef.
It's like how do you cook stuff fast to produce the least toxins that you
perform better on it.
This is so fast.
And it was this a long journey for you?
Yeah,
for 15 years.
I mean I spend a quarter million dollars upgrading myself and I started like
tracking how I felt and how I was performing and was I gaining weight or losing
weight and did my joints hurt and all this stuff.
And I came to this conclusion that you can't change one variable and expect
something to work.
You've got to change a lot of variables at once and then start adding things
back in.
Because let's say you're allergic to just like milk and wheat,
which so many people are,
oh this week I'll no wheat,
nothing changed this week I'll eat no dairy,
nothing changed.
So you assume nothing happened.
The problem is there's many things that cause inflammation at its core.
The bulletproof diet is about reducing inflammation.
And here's the secret.
When you look at a food,
there's three ways of looking at it.
The first one is does it have the right macronutrients?
So like if I needed to eat some protein or I need to eat some,
some fat,
is it in there?
But here's the funny thing,
people don't think about it so much.
You know,
if we said,
look,
you need to get 200 grams of protein today,
we generally say,
yeah,
that's good,
but wait a minute.
Okay,
this little vial of protein is the act of protein that's in black widow spider
venom.
And this is an egg,
okay?
How many grams of protein you want to eat today?
Okay?
The bottom line is different proteins do different things to your body.
So you've got to pick the right protein in there.
And then the fats.
Do you want hydrogenated vegetable oil or do you want coconut oil?
They're totally different on what they do to your body.
So first you got to get those sorted out.
And then the second way you look at your food is something called anti
nutrients.
And this is something that that most modern nutritionist just don't pay
attention to.
Paleo people know about some but not others.
And what's going on there is food has a defense mechanism built in.
If you're a grain,
your job was to reproduce and that means you coat yourself in pesticide to keep
the bugs from eating your so you can reproduce.
It's natural pesticide is called [inaudible] acid and it inhibits whatever eats
you and inhibits their ability to absorb minerals from their food.
So now what would I do when I look at food?
Does it have the right macronutrients?
Doesn't have poison in it?
If so,
then I don't want to eat it.
And finally,
does it have a lot of other stuff like B vitamins and minerals and the other
micronutrients you had guys like this Andy Guy,
that aggregate nutrient index guy at whole foods Ferman,
who by the way thinks Kales,
you know,
basically next to god he puts liver like at a very low number on there.
Yet liver has a lot more nutrients in it than Kale does.
The problem is he decided to divide by calories for reasons I don't quite
understand what's going on.
There is a focus on micronutrients,
ignoring anti nutrients and ignoring the function of food is fuel and they're
also doing that because they have a pro animal sort of an agenda.
Oh yeah.
There's definitely agenda behind that.
There's a lot of people,
like I've had conversations with people who are vegans
and they will tell you that it's only for health purposes and then I bring up
fish oil and most of them,
they don't take fish oil and I say,
well,
why?
If it's just for health reasons,
fish oil has been shown to be very,
very beneficial,
but it gets squirrely.
They start talking about eating flax seeds and shit.
You know if you're going to eat flax seeds,
flax seed oil oxidizes the second at Cs air,
like it's an incredibly unstable,
even in Ayurvedic Medicine,
they tell you,
you know flaxseed oil is a drying oil and your body can convert that to the
healthy Omega threes out a ratio of 40 to one you'll be 40 grams of flax oil.
You get one gram of the good stuff and you've got to dispose of the other 39
grams that cause inflammation in the body.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's why I don't recommend flips on its between fish oil.
It actually counteracts that and the fights inflammation,
which is why it's so great for grapplers.
Oh,
it's huge.
Yeah.
Guys are always in a lot of guys who are into crossfit as well and heavy doses
of fish oil.
Yeah.
It's an anti inflammatory,
right?
It's good stuff,
but I tell you,
if you use Krill,
it's going to work better because Krill has the same EPA and Dha,
but its phosphorolated.
It's bound to phospholipids,
which means that your brain can use it directly.
Fish oil.
It's gotta be phosphorolated and he's you.
You need to get extra phosphate.
I was searing,
I'm calling to do that in your diet.
So you have to take Coleen supplements.
If you take fish oil to get the October,
maybe just eat eggs except Coleen.
Yeah,
because here's the thing,
some of the like super strong coding supplements,
like if there's no question they have a really beneficial effect in like most
people in some people too much.
Coleen has like a reverse effect and it's probably like maybe a third of people.
So it is one of those things where if you get it in your food,
you're good.
And if the calling supplements make you feel really good,
which they do for the vast majority people,
like I'm a fan of Coleen supplements in general,
I recommend them on the blog.
Like you've got that ingredient in Alpha Beta and Alpha brain.
And like,
by the way,
that's just a killer list of nootropic ingredients.
I,
I fully,
fully approved that bulletproof level supplement for sure.
Awesome.
Thank you.
And uh,
the,
the thing is though,
if you're one of those Coleen sensitive people,
you might not want a ton of Coleen.
Like you want to limit yourself to a certain amount.
We've had issues with that with people getting really sensitive,
like draw attention and headaches.
Yeah,
yeah.
And those are the people who are calling dominant.
But here's the kicker.
You get those people to take antiacid Tam,
like the stuff I've got in my site and our acid tam uses up extra Coleen.
So that's an interesting way of using a smart drug.
And this is actually a drug,
not a,
not a natural substance,
but it's one that I'll bring your colon levels down,
which means you can benefit from the other stuff that's in,
um,
Alpha brain.
But you also get this boost from the other type of nootropic.
How many different things do you take a day?
Uh,
I take probably on an average day about 40 pills.
See,
I told you I'm not crazy.
I know.
Here's,
here's a crazy number.
When I was really focused on like,
like getting my health all the way where I wanted it before I was all the way.
Where am I did a 187 pills a day for several months.
Now.
What about the actual capsule itself?
What are those made out of gelatin?
Is that no big deal for your body,
the process you actually need gelatin our diets or gelatin deficient right now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And you know,
we eat all the muscles in the animal,
but in the old days or mom would boil the chicken and eat all the cartilage and
all that.
So I actually carry gelatin and Collagen on the site because when people eat
that stuff,
their joints get healthier.
And there's another thing and this whole electrical part of the body is not well
known,
but you know all those acupuncture Meridian points and things like that.
Well,
electricity flows through your skin,
not just in your nerves and you need collagen in your skin in order to,
to bring the water into the skin so you can carry electricity efficiently.
So when you eat enough collagen in the form of gelatin,
knocks blocks,
whatever,
I have grass fed gelatin that I use.
Whoa.
But you do that.
You actually,
you functioned better on many levels,
including on the inflammation level.
A lot of fighters are starting to take Jello.
And I noticed it in,
they did this,
I'm like sort of cribs thing with Minotauro.
Nogueira go.
Just fought a recently in UFC this past weekend and they went to his house.
He had a stack of Jello,
said he had,
this is make me feel good.
I mean it works even for sleep.
Sometimes it helps.
Hello?
I did not know.
The problem is like,
I mean industrial Jellos disgusting.
Like giving,
you want to know what's in there,
what is in there.
Like they,
they're taking a hooves and like snouts and like all these like office,
it's like the Bologna of protein powder.
It's not good.
Well,
I mean it,
it's better than no Collagen.
What's most,
what's the best made that the best is made out of the skin of the animal.
The skin.
Yeah.
So like that's the sort of stuff that,
that I use typically.
Um,
in fact next week I'll have,
um,
I'll have of listing for the,
the best kind of of it I've been exploring college and for years.
So you can take straight college and you can take straight gelatin and it's just
a question of basically how you want it to taste and how you want it to be
absorbed into your food.
But the old days we would make like soup from bones.
It's too much work.
So what you do now as you take a couple of scoops of collagen powder and you
just put it in your smoothie or putting in your soup and you've got all the
benefits of bone broth with none of the trouble.
It's just,
it's too much work to make all that prof no,
there's just a process.
They just take the,
the leather,
they take the outside and turn it into,
take the outside and they expose it to enzymes and a [inaudible] acid.
Yeah.
And that breaks it down and it's kind of a useful food.
It's one of those things that we used to fight for a hundred years ago because
you had to get enough of it.
And it was one of the ways of using the whole animal.
And now we just toss it.
And mostly so in your opinion and with all those things that you've researched,
what you found is that you can't even just not even like eggs is not good
enough.
Fish is not good enough.
Like you need animals,
you need mammals,
you need,
you need cows and shit.
At least some of the time.
I absolutely believe that.
I also believe,
let's face it,
you kill a chicken,
did one meal to kill that animal.
And chickens have the worst lives ever unless they're like super pastured,
crazy expensive chickens.
So like you want to be a tortured animal.
Modern chickens can't even stand up on their own because their breasts are so
big.
Like,
like they're one of the most tweak species.
Yeah.
They're pretty tweak.
It's pretty fucked up when you see one of those gigantic chicken farms and
they're all stacked on top of each other and it just crap on each other.
And also,
so I see these people,
I could never eat red meat.
I'm like,
dude,
one animal will feed two people basically for two years.
If they're eating normal amounts of it,
that's less death.
Yeah.
But it's a big death.
It's like nobody has a problem with killing ants.
People are not like making protests in front of a stores that sell raid ant
killer.
They don't give a fuck about the hands cause they're so small.
It's like we have like a thing that you could take an aunt like you find any on
any accountant gets dual your finger and do that and you just flick it on the
ground like you went away.
You can't do that to a rat.
You can't hit a rat with a hammer and it just throw it on the floor and now
you've got to clean that thing up.
The snail,
remember when it made that snail video and everyone got pissed off at me?
Yeah.
He can't kill snails.
Snails big enough.
He stomped on an ant.
No one would have given a shit.
But you killed a snail?
No,
like this son of a bitch.
I put a snail on a list of marines strip and it was awesome.
The thing about the thing about cows,
by the way,
he's almost 40 the,
the thing about cows,
those that they're big and like a,
you know,
an ant's tiny and it doesn't really bug us that you can buy poisoned for ants
anywhere.
If you could sell cowboys and at the store people would freak out because you
can't just kill cows like that.
They,
you know that you can buy rat poison.
Yeah.
The clients care about rats,
but then there's people who have rats for pets.
Like man,
there's a lot of people that actually lived off rats and the,
and what was it?
I forget Peru.
I believe we're Guinea pigs.
I like super common.
I've eaten a Guinea pig.
What is it like in Peru?
Yeah,
I went down there to do Iowasca with a showman and they have Guinea pig food.
it's native.
There they are.
Let me see the technical term for it.
Fucking disgusting.
There's like no meat on them and they stopped them with Rick rice and vegetables
don't taste good.
That's the,
there's like five bites of meat on a whole Guinea pig and it doesn't taste very
good.
The bites you can get and the rest of it's just like bones and skin.
It was the little family gross.
Those people are just trying to get by.
Yeah,
that's some tough times.
What I saw was this,
um,
Anthony Bourdain show and they went over this guy's house and they had Guinea
pigs running around the kitchen,
like constantly running.
They were everywhere and they would just pick one up,
take them over,
snap kill him,
got em and start cooking it.
And all these other dump Fox are just running around.
They're like their pets.
It's practically until they get killed.
But they have a concert,
you say it's awful,
but they have a constant supply of meat.
And your point of view from Burbank,
you know,
is very different than their point of view living in Peru.
There are two adorable though.
I yeah,
these houses don't even have windows.
Dude.
I used to have them as pets.
They are kind of cute but I got enough if I was hungry.
[inaudible] you have children and your children are hungry,
you're gonna eat the fuck out of some Guinea pigs and there they're everywhere.
Dude.
They have like 30 of them.
We had cat,
not on purpose but I've been to a lot of Taco trucks so I'm not sure.
Well do you think taco trucks really,
so really depends on where you are.
And I have a theory,
tell me if this theory makes any sense at all.
But I have a theory that things that are difficult to catch or good for you like
wild fish,
wild game,
things that run quick like deer,
deer.
Very good for you because they run fast to try and get the fuck away cause they
know that delicious.
They know there's what like highly sought after and then things like cows,
it just kind of stand around.
Probably not as good as anything to that theory.
I don't buy it either.
Here's why the thing humming dirt mark,
the things that can run really fast and sprint don't have enough fat on them.
Like when the Indians would kill a buffalo,
like the first thing you eat is like the big fatty hump on the back and then
that's,
that's a fat solid fat.
Is that like for storing food for them?
So in fact if you take a real grasp at buffalo that fat is orange.
It's actually like almost like a salmon color and most of the buffalo you can
buy it,
they finish on grand cause no one wants to buy orange fat.
I'm like man give me a big old like two pound hunk of orange fat like that.
Why can they,
I mean the most of it finishes on green or all of it come in,
can you get it?
It finishes on on,
I've asked that like butchers that really high end markets about that and
they're like yeah we were one of the guys said and we tried it one time at
orange,
we've got to throw it out.
No one would buy it.
That's so your probably order it online just to get it like a hundred percent
grass fed.
I need to get that.
Just to find out what it would taste like.
It's pretty delicious when you get like real fat.
In fact bisons good.
Even if you take like just the fats and good quality butter versus uh,
you know,
crap butter.
I've had like vegetarian friends,
I'm like,
come on over,
let me make one of my soups for you.
And it's,
you know,
butter and I use the MCT oil.
In fact,
next week I've got my bulletproof MCT oil,
like,
like on the shelves.
I'm super stoked on that.
What is it?
It's a six times stronger extract of coconut oil.
So it's two of the medium change.
The ones that are most responsible for losing weight and for cognitive function
where that's all that's in there and it has no flavor.
So you can like make Manet's out of it.
How's that created?
They take coconut oil and process that somebody has centrifuged.
Yeah,
so we spin it and then we pull out just those ones.
And I have the only brand I've,
I've heard anywhere.
What does that center future work?
So it's a,
basically you just spin it really fast and when they do like your blood tubes to
separate out the plasma and the and the cells when you spin it,
the different weights of fat line up.
So we pull out the two most precious ones right in the middle band there and
then we take the rest of it and we give that to other people.
It's ridiculous.
And this is coming out right now.
It's like it should be on the site right now.
Like you can preorder it.
I just put it out the bulletproof or bulletproof executive coms,
bulletproof exec.com bulletproof exact.com and you have your whole story is up
there of how you,
so for Po folks that don't have the patients to go and listen to this podcast
again,
there's a fuck load of information on this site as well as not just the upgraded
MCT oil.
You've got upgraded coffee,
everything's upgraded,
great chef.
And here's what it means when it's upgraded.
Like I'm looking at the whole process of making something and how do you make
that process as good as it can be.
Like my background,
I really am a computer hacker.
Like I've studied computer science,
I work in computer security.
I'm not an actively a hacker,
like I'm an executive.
But like I understand the mindset of changing a system to get the outcome you
want.
It turns out like to make the coffee.
The problem was actually how the beans get turned into green coffee.
That's where most the problems happen.
So I went through,
I learned all about all this stuff from multiple disciplines,
pulled it all together and said,
what if I created this new process for making coffee?
They didn't have the toxins in it.
And you look at that like we're about done with the study where we're getting
advice from Stanford University on the cognitive function of this coffee.
So we're comparing normal coffee versus this upgraded coffee to show what it
does to your response time and your attention.
And like we don't have enough results to be statistically significant yet we're
still recruiting people.
The results I have say yeah works.
So it's like this is real stuff.
And every step of the way when you create a food tells you how the food is going
to make you perform.
And what I'm trying to do is help people understand like if for one day they can
just have the best day ever where like their energy and their focus and
everything is super clear and they just like feel like a great golden God.
If you do that one time,
you know you're capable of it and you can start working towards that.
But most people I know have felt like crap without knowing it most of their
life.
They've never had a wonderful day.
Once you have that day you can learn how to kick more ass repeatedly.
So it's like get all the crap out of that.
I just do it right for a week and just see what can happen.
You look at the comments on my blog,
like people,
they do this,
it takes like six weeks.
It's not that hard to do and all of a sudden like you know you have twice the
energy you had before.
Like that's what I'm looking to do for people.
And when you have twice the energy,
you get twice the shit done.
I tell you,
I mentioned I'm a full time executive.
I wrote this book,
Wiley's my publisher Gary Tobbs introduced me to my agent in New York.
Like it's a tier one book with 1300 references.
I started the bulletproof executive blog,
which is in the top 25,000 blogs now,
150,000 people a month.
See yet.
Uh,
and I'm a dad of two young kids.
I see them on a very regular basis.
Like for me to be able to do all this stuff,
I could have never done this in my mid twenties it's cause I trained my brain
because I got my mitochondria functioning and I got my hormones functioning.
You looked at the body like your computer system.
Absolutely.
And where are you the first kind of do that?
You know,
there's,
there aren't that many computer guys.
Like I'm 40 and the oldest computer guys are like 65 right.
So certainly we've talked for years about this and there's,
you know,
the whole cyber punk thing,
which I admit,
I admit I was a part of,
you know,
mirrored sunglasses and stuff like that.
But I'm one of the early guys like,
um,
a lot of the Russians,
the Russian space program did a lot of this stuff.
Like this is a device,
this is called a is an older one,
but it's the only one you can get that does,
that does programming where you can pick the frequency.
But I'll run a current across my brain.
This is actively at the same thing you do to a computer.
When you do that,
you can put yourself in the gamma state.
That's really hard to get into.
You just stick the electrodes on your head and where that puts you in a gamma
state.
And what's the benefit of that?
Gamma state is actually a state where the Dalai Lama just a announced a cash
reward for anyone who could help him get into a gamma state in less than four
hours.
Cause that's how long it takes him.
He's looking for neuroscience ways to do it.
So literally you stick these things on your forehead as a Dalai Lama.
Try the isolation tanks.
I don't know,
but it wouldn't surprise me.
He's pretty open with his neuro neuroscience stuff.
But you hook this thing up,
you turn it on like that and now it's running.
You start good.
It sounds like you're,
it sounds like a Frankenstein or something.
What are you doing?
So
it's grass fed.
What I'm doing now,
I'm running,
running my brain is crap.
Sematic and grass fed drink.
So what you do something like that.
It is literally like you watered,
changing the waves in your brain like a computer.
And what is the benefit of that?
Again,
like when you put that on,
what is it actively do to you?
It depends on what setting you put it on.
If I'm going to be writing like a lot,
I'll put it on a gamma state and you're just in this like focused,
amazing kind of flow state.
Although Alpha is also something that's more recognized as a flow state,
so you can control what state your brain is in.
You want to get like rapid recovery during sleep.
If I'm only going to sleep two hours,
I put that on and I put it on 1.5 hertz,
which is associated with deep sleep.
And when I wake up I feel really good.
I didn't get all the benefits of memory consolidation and dreaming.
Do you sell this thing?
No.
You can just buy it.
Do you explained it on your website or anywhere?
Yeah,
I have a top 10 brain hacks.
Video is a talk.
I gave it south by southwest on this.
I would love to try that.
And so it's giving a low level electrical signal.
Yup.
And what does it do exactly?
In fact,
I have a touching the head.
So it's sending electrical waves in the brain.
It's running a slight current back and forth.
I try that one again.
Yeah,
sure.
I've had,
I got one.
You got me one a while ago.
We were trying to get you to quit smoking and didn't work.
You've never used it either?
No,
I used it a lot.
It's just,
it's shocked I stick those things on your forehead.
Yeah.
I'd like clips to your ears,
right?
It was a little freaky.
Yeah,
this one you said of your clips,
but I used to,
yeah,
I use the temple things just because they're a little easier.
Yeah.
And uh,
this is actually like a 10 year old device.
The problem is most of the new ones have only one frequency and this one lets
you adjust the frequencies,
which is,
which is helpful.
Okay.
I'm putting on my head and hit the power button on there or just hand me the
controls if you want it.
Okay.
How are you up?
Stay posted later.
Alright.
That feels weird.
There's a volume control right here.
It's Ding in my head.
It feels like there's up turn up,
turn that volume control until it doesn't stain.
It feels like a bee who's like trying to like say he's playing a game of just
the tip.
There you go.
These playing just the tip of the Stinger is not quite seem like,
come on man.
Just let me get the Zyban.
Yeah.
Um,
just,
it feels interesting.
Turn.
Turn it down so it doesn't hurt,
that's for sure.
What is it at now?
I turned it up.
Okay.
Is that bad?
It hurts.
No,
it's not bad,
but it'll still work if you just have a little tiny tingle that you do.
You don't want to get really smart.
If I have to fucking suffer through a little bit of pain,
I'm down to it.
If you do this for 1520 minutes for the next several hours,
the Alpha and the front half of your brain will be much higher than it was
before.
Why doesn't everybody know about this?
This is ridiculous.
Iphone could do this.
How serious.
It's not that hard.
This could be an APP.
It,
well,
I mean,
you'd have to set the iPhone up to do that,
but this whole quantified self thing I do like there's a whole bunch of people
looking at this stuff.
How long before the government arrested you for all this?
You know,
I didn't create super people.
Well,
the only thing that I've invented that's,
that's like new.
Some of the training techniques are different,
but like I didn't invent cerebral electrical
stimulation the Russians did in their space program.
The reason that this came about is they said it costs a lot of money to send a
cosmonaut up into space.
What if we didn't have,
if they didn't sleep,
we could send one third less cost the knots.
So they built this,
well I have a uh,
one of those turbo sonic machines.
I know that you've talked very highly of those things to tell me what those do.
Cause somebody told me when I bought it and I forgot,
but I use it all the time.
Oh yeah.
Awesome.
Those things rock.
So I'll tell you flat out,
you know,
if you can afford 12 or 15 grand by the turbo sonic,
I've used one for almost a year.
It's the most programmable and it's the quietest,
but does the same thing that these other ones do.
Any of the ones that vibrate you up and down only are going to have the same
effect.
There's a whole bunch of cheap ones that do like a side to side rocking that
messes up your low back.
So,
and also they tend to break.
I've broken welds on a couple of the stoop units.
It's some sort of an soundwave with speaker mechanism.
It's not really a sound wave with turbo sonic,
but it is a speaker mechanism.
You've seen like a Woofer,
like a heavy duty subwoofer and it goes doon,
doon,
doon.
What's going on there is they took the sound baffles off,
but they left us those speaker coil.
So it moves you up using that really efficient way of moving that speaker uses.
It's very precise.
I'm the one that I have that costs 10% as much to make it like within reach for
the normal person.
It uses a motor,
so it's louder,
but it has exactly the same up and down vibration that the turbo sonic would
have.
And there's another brand called power played out there and they're all based on
very similar principles and that's that when you vibrate the body like that,
you're triggering something called PSO electric signals in the bone.
So it increases bone density.
Your muscles have to keep tensing and releasing,
tensing and releasing.
So you actually can build muscle on those,
especially if you know you hold a kettle bell.
Um,
you know,
just hold out like this.
Like all of a sudden,
30 times a second.
You know,
you're doing this,
and I hate to say this is like the adult version of the shake weight,
but it's powered and it seriously works in the final thing you get from this has
to do with uh,
lymphatic circulation in the body.
So we have this whole waste,
the waste elimination system called your lymph system.
And the way the lymph moves is you have to move your body.
And this is why people say,
Oh,
you have to move.
Movement is so important for you move.
It's important because it moves lymph.
It's not cause it burns calories,
it doesn't burn calories.
That's a distraction.
Movement doesn't burn calories when it burns calories,
but that doesn't make you lose weight.
Like compared to say,
a short high intensity interval will make you lose more weight than going for a
walk that burns more calories in the end.
The high intensity interval,
it's a hormonal effect you're getting.
This is like Dr Doug Mic,
uh,
macduffs work.
Uh,
so I met gfes work,
um,
from body by science.
Like there's definitely like enormous loads of research there about caloric
consumption from exercise and diet and they don't line up for weight loss.
They just,
in fact,
yeah,
I have a really good blog post about that.
Whoa.
In fact,
the blog post is called,
it's not the calories stupid and it was in response to a New York Times piece
where they actually wrote it's the calorie stupid.
Even though the study that they'd written about showed it wasn't the calories
like different people at the same amount of calories and gain different amounts
of fat.
Like how did that happen?
But
uh,
on the vibration plate,
you're of course you're,
you're burning energy but you're moving all the lymphatic fluids in the body and
your micro capillaries are getting stimulated to like parts of you get shaken
that might not normally get circulation.
So you typically feel like a burst of energy when you're done with it and you,
you tend to slim down.
Like I noticed like especially if you have inflammation going on,
I'm still,
because of my health background,
I still,
I get inflamed.
He's ate the wrong stuff.
I puff up,
you do that and it helps you to dump the extra inflammation.
So it's amazing detox plus exercise plus general stimulation of your body all at
once.
Like for 15 minutes a day.
It's,
it's a total bargain just in terms of time spent,
whether it's on a turbo sonic or or the bulletproof vibe,
they,
they both achieve the same kind of goals,
but I'll tell you flat out you've got the Cadillac or the Mercedes of them,
the turbo sonic to the best made anywhere.
Yeah,
I do 10 minutes of it before a workout.
Yeah.
I'll do a 10 minute like shakedown.
Like you really look at it.
It feels good,
doesn't it?
It feels amazing.
I love that feeling.
It's amazing.
And then when it really,
what's really going fast for folks who've never tried it before,
if you,
if you're anywhere near Venice,
whoops,
I lost one of my fucking Frankenstein.
No lobes.
If you're anywhere near Venice,
the float lab has it.
Crash is the one who sold me mine.
He's the fucking mad scientists,
ladies and gentlemen to given me an updated tank.
Ladies and gentleman,
there's a new tank.
Did crash is created.
It's even though he's a mad scientist,
he's a crazy man,
but he uh,
he runs the float lab,
the best isolation tanks bar none in the world.
I might get one.
I'm,
I'm looking at one.
How the fuck do you not have one?
I've been looking at building one,
but because I moved up to BC a couple of years ago and look at it by a ranch.
So as soon as I get the ranch,
I'm getting a good tank,
but I don't want to move it into the place where I'm living now.
You should have it right in this crash.
We'll set it up and do everything for you.
You should have one right now.
Especially you.
How many times have you used,
well,
I've used the float tank once,
like 10 years ago.
Dare you sir?
Hooking up these fucking electrodes to your brain.
You're not even taking advantage of one of the craziest pieces of,
Oh,
I have machine I love.
So I love it.
It's a huge thing.
You only did it once.
I only did it once.
It's a question of where you live,
right?
If there's not a float tank area and yeah,
it,
it's on my list.
Not for me it wasn't.
I did it once and I was looking to buy a house and one of the prerequisites for
buying the house was having a room for the tank.
My,
the House I'm looking to buy right now,
same thing.
It's got to have space.
I have to have space for a pool table.
I have to have space for the tank that's non negotiable.
Everything else I can lift weights at the gym,
but they need a tank in the house.
It's hard to find a tank,
you know,
if you don't live near Venice.
The tank for me is something that anyone who's thinking about improving must
have for creativity.
It is.
It's a fascinating tool,
self introspective thinking and you know,
it's just,
it's amazing.
In fact,
it's one of those technologies and there's a whole bunch of them out there that
allows the prefrontal Cortex,
like the human part of your brain that you think of as you to become aware of
that,
that really fast reptilian brain that runs circles around you like you.
You can't even see it happening until you get rid of all the noise.
And when you get into that flow tank all of a sudden like you do that personal
exploration,
you can,
you can do amazing
things there.
You can do amazing things and you learn amazing things out about yourself.
You start making these drastic improvements in the way you look at things in
there.
Cause it's so self analytical.
It's so,
it's so a self observational.
Then when you're in there you just,
you're not,
you don't have anything going on with your body.
So you're just alone with your thoughts and you have to address them.
You can't get confused and separated with busy work.
You just,
you're,
you're not going to within 20 minutes anything that's really fucking with you.
We'll come to the surface.
Have you ever played with neurofeedback?
What does that,
this is when you hook electrodes up to your head and you get the signal from
your brain,
oh,
this is profound stuff.
It,
it's on par with a float tank.
In fact,
I've had my own EEG since 1998.
Whoa.
Um,
be like at home because it's that impactful and what you do there is,
is your brain,
it's unable to see itself.
Like your brand can see the whole world around you,
but it doesn't have nerves inside itself.
That's why I like you see brand surgery,
they can take the top off your head and like poke at your brain and it doesn't
hurt.
There's no nerves in there.
There's nurses in your arm,
like you cut your arm.
Then what's going to happen is,
well,
there's nerves there and in the arm heals relatively quickly.
We get these traumatic brain injuries.
They don't heal very well because the brain doesn't even know what's broken.
So it's incredibly good at the world,
incredibly bad at itself.
So what you do is you get the signal from the brain,
you'd play it through an amplifier,
it turns it into music and it plays the music back to you.
And when you think about something in the music gets louder.
When you think about something else,
music gets quieter.
So you can teach the brain to think in a new way.
So I've done an extensive neurofeedback training and literally seven days was
the equivalent of 40 years of daily zen practice.
This was really,
really hardcore intense seven days.
It was like a hardest thing I've ever done.
It cost me 20 grand and I was hooked up to it like an $11 million EEG machine
for at least half that time.
But I mean you want to introspection when you look at a,
when you hear a sound,
your brain can't help but optimize itself.
Like it tells you when you're doing it wrong.
You think of like the meditation path that people are on there.
Like,
oh,
I meditate this way.
Oh I did it wrong for five years,
sorry.
And then they do it over here and they sort of meander.
And then you know their teachers tell them,
try meditating this way.
Well what if there was a computer and it lit up the path.
So like on either side of the path there's like letting you know the sounds get
quiet and either side of the path.
All of a sudden you can do meditative type of things to yourself that would take
you years of focused practice.
You can do it in days and because synaptogenesis this part of the brain that
makes new synapses happens within like 20 days.
You can totally rewire your head in short,
short amounts of time,
like unbelievably short.
So you rewire your head by use of electrical frequencies so you can literally
program it to do exactly what you wanted to do.
Right?
But we're not putting the frequencies into the head.
All we're doing is we're using like a mirror because the brain doesn't have any
nerves inside itself.
The brain will on its own figure out,
oh my God,
that sound,
that's me.
And it'll start doing things to like adjust how it works.
It's like for things like add people who have like been hit on the head,
these guys,
they,
they get improved very dramatically.
But the kind I did is correlated with a 12 IQ point,
boost that stable year later
and like 50% more creativity.
Wow.
Amazing.
Wait a minute.
What do we have to do?
How do I get it on this?
Um,
well I will,
uh,
I'll hook you up with a guy who does it.
He runs a private facility.
How much time?
It takes seven full days and takes 15 grand plus travel expenses.
Sounds like I'm getting robbed.
It's,
is it behind a seven 11 nonsense.
The Guy,
the guys in
ex,
uh,
he's an ex faculty member from UCS staff.
Yeah.
He's been doing this for 35 years and then runs a private facility.
By the way,
you're getting robbed.
This should be available on every street corner and it should be in every school
and it should cost about 300 bucks.
It would transform society.
The fact that it's 15 grand pisses me off everyday,
which is why I'm not telling you his name right now because shut this website
down anyway.
But yeah,
we will crush you a websites on that sounds like really for seven days though.
It actually doesn't sound like a rip off if it turns into a super genius.
It sounds like it was.
I mean I,
I'd already done a lot of work on myself,
but I came out of there and like the voice in your head that,
that thing that gets in your way,
like it's your bitch when you're done.
Like that's so you can go there and it just completely rewires your brain in
seven days.
It is hard work.
Don't get me wrong.
You have to do what is the hardware.
You sit there in a dark room with a speaker on either side of your head and
eight electrodes glued to your head and then you,
you do whatever you have to do to make the sound louder and make your score go
higher.
And the first three days you just like your brain just doing his thing.
And then after that you have to dig in on like you're,
you're most like,
it's just like in a float tank.
My ultimate fantasy,
it would be that I'd go there and I'm like a super gifted at this and I break
the whole,
we're getting,
we're getting to that point.
So we didn't do this.
I want you to do this.
I think it's not going to judge all.
I'll do it with you.
I've actually been thinking about going back.
Can you lay on top of each other women?
Can you get the super would if she would like a fucking intellectual vampire now
get dumber and you get smarter.
Um,
what if he hacks?
That's what he's trying to do.
I'd like to remind you,
you've gotten my electrodes on your forehead right now.
It's already been done
to bill this shit,
son.
You got to meet some little stronger for this fat head.
What is this thing?
I think I saw it on your Twitter about you paying to get hacked.
What was that all about?
Paying for what?
Maybe it,
hold on.
Nevermind
mean biohacking.
How much you spent biohack the quarter million dollars.
Yeah.
Okay.
So over the past 15 years,
I've spent a quarter million dollars on everything I can think of that improves
human performance.
I'm like,
I'm just going to do it.
So,
um,
20 grand.
Actually I did it a couple times.
So 20 grand in 25 grand,
whatever there.
Um,
I've taken ungodly numbers of supplements and smart drugs.
I've tried all kinds of electronics.
I have like a whole mad biohacker laboratory at home.
Like I've gotten my vibrating plate.
I've got an ozone generator.
I've got a couple different EEG machine zone generator in my tank set up because
of crashed uses.
Purify the water.
That's the best way to purify water.
Powerful crush.
Are you,
are you sponsored by grass to pay for all this Scott Industries or something?
Actually BC bud.
That's fine.
Have you ever looked into eating cannabis?
Um,
as a,
as a food?
Yeah.
Um,
I've looked at eating hemp,
not,
you mean you didn't have actual cannabis?
Cannabis is when you don't cook it.
It's not psychoactive.
Eat it.
The psychoactive plants of cannabis.
If you eat it does not make you high.
It just just by,
but it's incredibly healthy.
Oh,
interesting.
Beneficial.
Yeah.
And that's supposed to,
I've never tried it but it sounds kind of cool.
It's supposed to be really great to juice as well and interesting.
That's really cool.
Well,
if it was legal,
it'd be so easy and cheap to grow that you could literally eat it that way for
health,
smoke it,
do whatever you want.
You wouldn't be such a,
the reason why it's such a commodity is because it's illegal.
It's ridiculous.
You could throw seeds out the window mean it's famous people who have been
driving their car,
they throw joints out the window,
they drive by six months later as a fucking giant push of marijuana growing
there.
I mean it really is a super hardy plant and,
and like the protein in there is really high in Igg.
It's great protein.
It's a bit high in Omega six fats.
Um,
if it's all you're going to eat,
but certainly some of it,
it's fine.
But,
but if you get those protein,
it's one of effect.
I would say it's the best plant source protein that I know of.
Yeah.
You can need a plan.
Sorry.
It's very digestible to,
that's my favorite part of it is that it's the one of the few things hemp with
coconut juice and coconut oil,
but uh,
I use it with a c two oh baby see two oh coconut juice because it is my favorite
if I can get raw.
Raw is Roz,
awesome.
Ross,
tough to fuck with if you can get robbed but it only lasts for like a little
while.
It's the best.
You can't really keep it in the fridge like you can,
but that damn stuff and force protein part of the stuff that I use.
Yeah,
you could,
you could take it and go to the gym and hour later it's the only thing that I
could do Jujitsu and an hour later because it's so easy for your body digest.
It's just not taxing at all.
The stuff we use.
Two is the most expensive because it has the highest ratio of protein to like to
like some of our more course of the hearts are more course.
They don't have as high a ratio.
That's what you want to do.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's really super easily digestible but illegal to grow but not illegal to have
or sal,
so like,
like legal.
Thank you Canada,
the United States for fucking saying that it's illegal to grow a plant.
Dunces it's just such,
you know,
we add on it.
We could have had a farm we were thinking about like Vermont,
we looked into Vermont because Vermont passed laws,
but the federal government is clearly said,
we will lock you in jail if you try to grow this plant.
Here's,
here's how to get past all of this.
I just figured it out.
Oh,
Monsanto needs to make genetically modified pot and then it'll be legal to grow
everywhere.
Listen.
Yeah.
But then they'll probably fuck with a pot and the pot transmit Nazi,
turn you into an octopus or something.
Yeah.
It's going to do something to you.
It's going to ruin you.
I hope they don't do that and case anyone there's listening.
Yeah,
please.
Monsanto leave.
We'd alone concentrate on sweet potatoes or whatever the fuck you're doing.
It's this scary ass company,
man.
Somebody needs to get those people some mushrooms.
Amen.
Get those people some mushrooms and understand the impact of your decisions.
Just to put ones and Zeros.
There's some serious therapeutic value to medicinal mushrooms.
Oh fuck yeah.
That's John Hopkins University showed significant improvements in people's
personalities years later.
How many,
how many kilobytes is Joe's brain being downloaded like,
like that's like a 32 megabyte file are pretty smart right now.
Brian,
I know he's,
he's taking,
he just copied and pasted parents.
Yeah.
I don't even know what my own memories or I'm actually on my iPad here.
I'm looking at what he's thinking about and I feel dirty,
dirty,
not black hawks.
And that's your,
that's a flashback.
Flashback to the past sun.
How dare you.
Are you feeling anything from the electrodes?
Um,
I don't know.
You know,
it's hard to say and I'll feel bad.
It gives me a pretty subtle and just,
you know,
see if you're in the zone one more for the next few hours after this.
Yeah,
I think it's,
it feels cool.
I like it.
I liked the fact that I think it does something for me.
But this other thing just fucking seven day jammy.
That sounds,
uh,
how many hours a day?
Pretty much.
Most of them,
like,
like you,
when you get there,
you check in your watch and your cell phone and you just like do it until you're
done.
You don't even pay attention to the time.
Like it's just like time goes away.
And all your folks who have done this,
10,000,
10,000 people have done this and they've all reported similar results.
Army special forces had this sky train them for seven months straight.
So it's like a Jason Bourne type thing.
Really.
So there's a way you can go and you sit down in this fucking place for seven
days and this is a permanent change in your Iq and your creativity.
Yup.
That's started kickstarted for you,
Joe.
We're going to make a movie about this
bitch.
I don't need,
I don't need that man.
I'm telling you,
man,
it for you.
You're talking about like,
you know,
add,
uh,
you know,
just like kind of have in your brain,
that's a comedian.
Brands all over the place.
You don't lose any of that creativity,
but it becomes malleable for you.
And like my,
my performance,
I did this in like 2008 or 2007,
I think.
2000.
No.
Anyway,
mid two thousands.
Um,
and I dunno,
like I came back,
I drive fast.
I've always driven fast.
I'm a very safe driver,
but when someone in a Prius cuts me off,
it pisses me off.
Right?
And it's always the priestesses of cut you off.
So you know,
like you son of a bitch and when I've dealt with this,
I came back,
I'm like,
oh,
it's one of the priests cut me off,
but zero emotional like costs.
All the energy that I used to waste on,
like getting pissed off about stuff that didn't matter completely went back to
productivity and like just kicking more ass.
It's amazing what happens when you just teach your brain that you're the boss
and you tell you the little reptile brain and they're just shut the hell up and
to do its job to keep you from burning yourself to death or falling off a cliff,
but to not be freaking out the rest of the time for no reason.
Is it possible to do that without sitting in a room for seven days?
Get blasted with sounds.
You can do.
Give me some sound.
Alright,
give me,
give me a feel like a simulation.
Yeah.
What you think this could be black.
There you go.
Something like that.
It's kind of like that and then you try and make it louder.